Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist across Beijing declaring war on the past. We want to take to task and smash all old ideas, old culture, old customs, old habits, the poster read. Barbers, tailors, photographers, book peddlers and others who are at the service of the bourgeois class, none of these are exceptions. We want to rebel against the old world. The next day, roving gangs of youthful enthusiasts for this message, Red Guards as they were called, began roaming across the Chinese capital, attacking anything that smacked of the old way of doing things.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先收听权限，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist。北京拉开了向过去宣战的序幕。海报上写道：“我们要向所有旧思想、旧文化、旧风俗、旧习惯发起挑战并将其砸烂。”理发师、裁缝、摄影师、书贩以及其他服务于资产阶级阶层的人，无一例外。我们要对旧世界进行造反。第二天，成群结队、对这一号召充满热情的年轻人（他们被称为红卫兵）开始在中国的首都四处游荡，攻击任何带有旧时代做事风格痕迹的事物。
Old street names, barbershops, high heels, all were targeted by the Red Guards. A few days later in Shanghai, the Red Guards there started attacking flower beds, cats. Dominic, in view of our forthcoming program that we have on pigeons, racing pigeons were targeted. You're absolutely incorrigible on this pigeons issue, Tom. Well, pigeons keep cropping up in history and they cropped up in the Cultural Revolution, which of course is what I'm describing. And in due course, ancient monuments were targeted, classical literature, paintings and temples. And this in turn was part of an even broader convulsion that affected the whole of China for years and years. And I in turn was part of an even broader convulsion that affected the whole of
旧路名、理发店、高跟鞋，都成了红卫兵的目标。几天后在上海，那里的红卫兵开始攻击花坛和猫。多米尼克，考虑到我们即将制作的关于鸽子的节目，赛鸽也成了目标。汤姆，你在鸽子这个问题上简直无可救药。好吧，鸽子在历史上总是不断出现，它们也出现在文化大革命中，而这当然就是我正在描述的。顺理成章地，古代遗迹成了目标，古典文学、绘画和寺庙也未能幸免。而这反过来又是席卷全中国多年的一场范围更广的大动荡的一部分。而我反过来又是席卷全中国的
China for years and years. And I'm quoting here from Frank de Kerta, whose book, The Cultural Revolution, is a brilliant guide to it. And he writes that between one and a half and two million people were killed, but many more lives were ruined through endless denunciations, false confessions, struggle meetings, and persecution campaigns. And Dominic, as a representative of the bourgeois, a historian, writing for the Daily Mail, how do you think you would have done in the Cultural Revolution? Yeah, I think my time would have been up on day one, Tom. I mean, not least, I've just had a haircut, as you can tell. I mean, the listeners can't see this. So this business about barbers would have been very bad news for me, because I'm very clearly a man who's just been to the barbers.
中国多年的一场范围更广的大动荡的一部分。在此我引用弗兰克·德克特的著作《文化大革命》，这是一本极佳的导读之书。他写道，有一百五十万到二百万人被杀害，但还有更多人的生活被无休止的批判、虚假的供词、斗争会和迫害运动所毁。多米尼克，作为资产阶级的代表、为《每日邮报》撰稿的历史学家，你觉得自己在文化大革命中会怎么样？是的，汤姆，我想我第一天就得完蛋。我是说，最不用说的是，正如你所见，我刚理过发。我是说，听众们看不到这一点。所以关于理发师的这档子事对我来说可不是什么好消息，因为我显然是一个刚去过理发店的人。
What is it about barbers? That's the peculiar thing. Anyway, I think that cultural revolution is such an unbelievably colorful and fascinating topic. But it's also probably the single most – we've done, I don't know how many podcasts we've done, the best part of 200 podcasts now, Tom. And I think this is the single most depressing, horrific story we've done. Because
理发师到底怎么了？这才是奇怪的地方。总之，我认为文化大革命是一个极其丰富多彩且迷人的话题。但它可能也是单一最具——我们做过，我不知道我们做过多少播客了，汤姆，现在差不多有200期精彩的播客了。而我认为这是我们做过的最令人沮丧、最可怕的故事。因为
to me, as a Western bourgeois outsider, it seems to represent the ultimate descent into, to me, it seems like mindless barbarism. But of course, it isn't, because there were interesting political shenanigans and ideological kind of maneuver maneuverings behind it all and that's the fascinating thing that actually this is rooted in often quite cold-blooded political calculation do you think that for a historian it has a kind of particular horror simply because of the attack on the past and i a question i would love to put to um probably the greatest contemporary historian of china that we have here in britain rana metta who is professor of the greatest contemporary historian of China that we have here in Britain, Rana Mitter, who is Professor of the History and Politics of Modern China at
对我这个西方资产阶级局外人来说，它似乎代表了彻底堕落为——在我看来，这就像是无意识的野蛮行径。但当然，事实并非如此，因为在这背后有有趣的政治权谋和意识形态上的运筹帷幄，而这才是最迷人的地方：实际上，这往往植根于相当冷酷的政治计算。你认为对于历史学家来说，仅仅因为对过去的攻击，它就带有一种特有的恐怖感吗？我有一个很想抛出的问题，对象是——嗯，大概是我们英国现存最伟大的中国当代史学家、牛津大学中国现代史与政治学教授……
Oxford, author of A Bitter Revolution, China's Struggle with the Modern World, but more recently, two brilliant books on China and the Second World War, one detailing the war with Japan, one on China's relationship to the Second World War, also presented for Free Thinking on Radio 3, and also very much a rival podcast now. So we're very pleased to get him on ours. Rana, thanks so much for joining us. And could I just, I mean, just put to you that question. As a historian of China, do you find the spectacle of destruction that the Cultural Revolution unleashed against the kind of the monuments and the records and the traditions of China? Do you find it upsetting?
牛津大学中国现代史与政治学教授拉纳·米特（Rana Mitter）。他是《苦难的革命：中国与现代世界的抗争》一书的作者，最近还出版了两本关于中国与第二次世界大战的精彩著作，一本详细讲述了对日战争，另一本讲述了中国与第二次世界大战的关系；他还为三台（Radio 3）主持过《自由思考》（Free Thinking）节目，如今也是我们强有力的播客竞争对手。所以我们非常高兴能邀请他上我们的节目。拉纳，非常感谢你加入我们。我想请教你这个问题：作为一名中国历史学家，对于文化大革命对中国的种种古迹、档案和传统所释放出的这种毁灭景象，你是否会感到沮丧？
Tom, thanks so much for a great question. I have to say before I even answer that question, I must also express my delight at being on a legendary podcast, which I've had recommended, not least by a diplomat from a major Anglophone country who took me by the arm when I was having a drink with him in London and saying, you have to listen to Tom and Dom's podcast. That is the one that we're all listening to as well. So great to actually be on. I think you're absolutely right. But those of us who actually ply history for a trade, those who actually care very much about the preservation of the past, the interpretation of the past, saving what has survived from the rough and tumble of everyday life
汤姆，非常感谢你提出这么棒的问题。我必须说，在回答这个问题之前，我也必须表达我能够参加这个传奇播客的喜悦之情——这个播客不仅得到了推荐，而且推荐者还是一位主要英语国家的外交官。当时我在伦敦和他喝东西，他抓住我的胳膊说：“你一定要听汤姆和多姆的播客，那是我们大家都在听的节目。”所以能真正来到这里真是太棒了。我认为你说的完全正确。那些以历史为业的人，那些非常关心过去的保护、对过去的解读、以及将日常生活的风风雨雨中幸存下来的东西保存下来的人，
perhaps are particularly devastated by one of the things that emerged during the cultural revolution which was the way in which systematically and methodically pretty much every aspect of what was considered to be an unclean and problematic past the past that essentially dated from before the revolution, was essentially taken out of circulation, destroyed, smashed, in some cases violently, in other cases almost more chillingly, methodically. You could find llama temples in Tibet, for instance, which were taken apart almost brick by brick and the bricks reused for more mundane uses, you know, pig pens or factories, whatever it might be. So the sense that the past not only should be left behind, but should be erased almost to
或许会对文化大革命期间涌现出的某一现象感到特别痛心，那就是：系统且有条不紊地，几乎所有被视为不干净、有问题——本质上可追溯到革命前——的过去，都被彻底清除出流通领域、遭到毁灭、砸毁；在某些情况下是暴力的，而在另一些情况下则更令人不寒而栗，是有条不紊的。例如，你可以在西藏发现一些喇嘛庙，它们几乎是被一块砖一块砖地拆解，而砖块则被重新用于更世俗的用途，比如猪圈或工厂，诸如此类。因此，那种认为过去不仅应该被抛在身后，而且应该被抹去直至
invisibility. That is indeed something very chilling about the heart of that cultural revolution idea. And one of the reasons I think historians do find it very, very troubling to contemplate. So Rana, set the scene for us, because a lot of our listeners won't be, well, I think I speak for lots of people a lot of our listeners won't be, well, I think I speak for lots of people of my generation, we didn't do any Chinese history at school or university. So there's been a revolution. Mao and the communists have taken power at the end of the 1940s. And then they're coming off the back of an equally ghastly experience, which is that the great leap, Mao's collectivisation of agriculture, and arguably, is it the greatest famine in world history, the greatest man-made famine?
形同虚无的感觉，确实是文化大革命核心中非常令人不寒而栗的东西。这也是为什么我认为历史学家在思考这段历史时会感到非常非常不安的原因之一。所以，拉纳，请为我们铺陈一下背景，因为我们的很多听众不会——嗯，我想我可以代表我这一代的大多数人，我们在学校或大学里都没有学过中国历史。所以，革命发生了，毛泽东和共产党人在20世纪40年代末夺取了政权。紧接着，他们又经历了一段同样惨痛的经历，那就是大跃进——毛泽东对农业的集体化，可以说是世界历史上最大规模的饥荒，最大的人为饥荒吗？
Must be up there. And we're talking about 20 to 30 million deaths caused by the Great Leap Forward. So it's huge in number, sure. And after that, Mao had... So Mao, who was the sort of great helmsman, the hero of the revolution, he had taken a bit of a back seat. Is that right? That he had been sort of pushed into the shadows a little bit. And is there some degree to which the Cultural Revolution is basically his great attempt to put himself back at centre stage and to sort of reclaim leadership of the party? The Cultural Revolution can be read in several ways, Dominic. One is that we have a leader who, as you say, has been sidelined and is trying in some ways to place himself at the heart of events again. But I think it's also important not to underestimate this is not just a power play.
可以说是首屈一指的。我们谈论的是因大跃进造成的2000万到3000万人的死亡。所以在数量上是非常巨大的。在那之后，毛泽东……那么，作为某种伟大舵手、革命英雄的毛泽东，曾退居二线。是这样吗？他被稍微挤到了阴影里。文化大革命在某种程度上，基本上是他试图将自己重新推回核心舞台并重新夺回党内领导地位的宏大尝试吗？多米尼克，文化大革命可以有几种解读。一种解读是，正如你所说的那样，我们有一位领袖被边缘化了，他正试图通过某种方式让自己再次成为事件的核心。但我认为同样重要的是，不要低估这不仅仅是一场权力博弈。
If it had been a power play, then China could have had what's happened in hundreds of countries around the world over the years. And that is a military coup. You basically get your mates in the army to kick out the leaders and instead put your own supporters in, and that's not what happened. In other words, it is also a genuinely ideological movement. It's a terrifying movement, in my opinion, but it is not one that is inauthentic. So let me just say a word or two about how China got to where it was in the summer of 1966 when the Cultural Revolution broke out. Essentially, the turmoil of the early 20th century, the invasion by various foreign countries and parts of China's territory, the placing of China under essentially a sort of economic sort of semi-colonialism. China was never a full colony, unlike India, but there were various aspects of its own policy, particularly tariff reform, that it was not allowed to carry out autonomously. So that led to a lot of resentment. You then get the invasion by Japan during World War II, which creates huge turmoil, refugee flight, death and destruction, and then a civil war
如果这只是一场权力博弈，那么中国本可以发生过去多年来世界上几百个国家都发生过的事情，那就是军事政变。你基本上是让军队里的老朋友把领导人赶下台，然后换上你自己的支持者，而这并不是发生的事情。换句话说，这也是一场真正的意识形态运动。在我看来，这是一场令人恐惧的运动，但它并不是不真实的。所以请允许我简单说一说中国是如何走到1966年夏天文化大革命爆发时的状况的。本质上，20世纪初的动荡、各种外国对中国领土的入侵、将中国置于一种经济上的半殖民地状态（中国从未像印度那样成为完全的殖民地，但在其自身政策的各个方面，特别是关税改革方面，它不允许自主实施），这导致了大量的怨恨。随后，你经历了二战期间日本的入侵，这造成了巨大的动荡、难民逃亡、死亡和毁灭，然后是内战。
between the rulers of China in the early 20th century, the nationalists under Chiang Kai-shek, and the communists who come to be ruled over by Mao Zedong, the man who become known as Chairman Mao. And eventually, the communists, through a combination of superior military tactics, a radical social policy, at least in the short term, does attract a lot of people, and also support from the Soviet Union, manages to overcome its nationalist opponents and place itself in power in 1949. In the words that have echoed down since, uttered by Mao and by others, the Chinese people had stood up and they had created this new communist state. So that carried on really for 17 years or so, the years of first of all, of massive land reform, tremendous violence, as well as reconstruction of society. And then the Great Leap Forward you mentioned,
交战双方是20世纪初中国统治者蒋介石领导的国民党人，以及由毛泽东（也就是后来被称为毛主席的人）领导的共产党人。最终，共产党人通过结合更优越的军事战术、激进的社会政策（至少在短期内吸引了大量民众），以及来自苏联的支持，战胜了国民党对手，并在1949年夺取了政权。用毛泽东和其他人发出并回响至今的话来说，中国人民站起来了，他们创建了这个新的社会主义国家。这实际上延续了大约17年，也就是首先进行大规模土地改革的岁月，期间伴随着巨大的暴力以及对社会的改造。然后就是你提到的“大跃进”，
which essentially is a failed economic experiment that tries to boost China's productivity, but ends up with a horrific situation that leads to millions of people starving to death in the countryside. So the beginning of the 1960s, Mao, who is the leader of the revolution, has been slightly sidelined by his colleagues not officially shamed or disgraced in any way but basically made it clear it's been made clear that they want to see a little bit less of him around and this is something that really hurts his self-esteem he regarded himself not not without justification as the ideological mover and shaker behind the communist coming to power in the first place and being moved aside was not something that he wanted to really to do. But beyond that, and this gets to the heart,
这本质上是一个失败的经济试验，旨在提高中国的生产力，但最终却演变成一场骇人听闻的局面，导致数以百万计的农民在农村饿死。因此，到了20世纪60年代初，作为革命领袖的毛泽东，被他的同事们稍微边缘化了——虽然没有遭到正式的羞辱或任何形式的失势，但基本上明确表示，他们希望少看到他一些。这确实深深伤害了他的自尊心，他认为自己（并非没有正当理由）是共产党人最终掌权的意识形态幕后推手，被推到一旁并不是他真心想做的事。但除此之外，这也触及了核心。
I think, of the ideology of the Cultural Revolution. By the early 1960s, Mao had become convinced that the revolution had lost its fire. He saw the Soviet Union where Stalin had died and Khrushchev had basically moderated the Soviet Union from its original, very radical revolutionary positions in various ways. And he said to himself that he didn't want the same sort of thing to happen in China. Because Mao is identifying himself with Stalin, right, and Stalin's policies. And then after Stalin's death, Stalin gets denounced by Khrushchev. And so is it right that Mao is anxious about the same fate befalling him? That's exactly right. Essentially, the relationship between Mao and Stalin was a very dysfunctional
我想，这就是文化大革命意识形态的核心。到了20世纪60年代初，毛泽东已经确信革命失去了火种。他看到了苏联的情况：斯大林去世后，赫鲁晓夫在各方面基本上修正了苏联最初非常激进的革命立场。他对自己说，他不希望中国发生类似的事情。因为毛泽东把自己等同于斯大林，对吧？以及斯大林的政策。而在斯大林死后，斯大林遭到赫鲁晓夫的批判。那么，毛泽东担心同样的命运会降临到自己头上，对吗？完全正确。本质上，毛泽东和斯大林之间的关系是非常失调的。
one. They both admired each other and also didn't trust each other any further they could throw each other. But that having been said, I think Mao always admired Stalin's decisiveness and his radicalism, and also actually his sort of violent disregard for individual human life. They had that very much in common between the two of them. So the discrediting of Stalin by Khrushchev in the Soviet Union was seen by Mao as a deeply hostile act towards him in China as well. And as a result of that, by the time you get to the early 1960s, Mao is beginning to feel all around him, not just that he's under pressure, that he's being encircled essentially by people who want to move him aside, but beyond that also that the Chinese revolution is in danger of becoming the kind of bourgeois revisionist revolution, as he would put it, that he saw in the Soviet Union. And that's
他们彼此钦佩，同时也对彼此充满猜忌。话虽如此，我认为毛泽东一直很钦佩斯大林的果断和激进，以及他对个体人类生命的暴力漠视。他们在这两点上有着极大的共识。因此，苏联的赫鲁晓夫对斯大林的否定，在毛泽东看来，也是对他在中国的极其敌对的行为。正因如此，到了20世纪60年代初，毛泽东开始感到周围危机四伏——不仅是他感到了压力，不仅是被那些想把他推开的人包围，而且除此之外，他也感到中国革命正面临着危险，正在变成他在苏联看到的那种资产阶级修正主义革命（正如他所称的那样）。这就是他焦虑的根源。
the source of his anxiety. Just a question about Mao. We've had a couple of questions from our listeners about this. So David Palmer asks a question about, so after the failure of the Great Leap Forward, I mean, Mao is what, he's late 60s, early 70s at this point. Why don't the other Chinese leaders, especially when he then launches the Cultural Revolution and there's all this chaos, why don't they just get rid of him? What's the problem? One thing which I think is in some ways difficult to recapture in the present day, but it's really worth understanding, is how central Mao made his own personality to the success of the Chinese Revolution as a whole. We tend to
关于毛泽东，我有一个问题。我们收到了听众提出的几个关于这方面的问题。大卫·帕尔默（David Palmer）问了一个问题：在大跃进失败之后——我的意思是，毛泽东当时已经60多岁快70岁了——为什么其他中国领导人，特别是当他随后发动文化大革命且出现所有这些混乱时，为什么他们不直接除掉他呢？问题出在哪里？有一点我认为在当今时代在某种程度上很难重新体会，但非常值得理解，那就是毛泽东将他自己的个性提升到了中国革命整体成功核心的地位。我们倾向于
think of the Cultural Revolution, and of course, we'll talk about this in more detail, I'm sure, in just a few minutes, as being the apotheosis, you know, the absolute final peak point of Mao's declaration of his own cultural personality, almost a godlike figure. But that didn't start in the 1960s. It really began in the 1940s in a period known as the rectification movement, when essentially acolytes, people who wanted to come and become part of the communist revolution, were made to undergo a training program in which they were both pressured psychologically very strongly to become part of the party, but also made to read a selection of books. And of 22 key texts, 18 were by Mao. In other words, he was very much placing his own thought, not just communist thought in general,
认为文化大革命——当然我们会在几分钟内更详细地讨论这一点——是毛泽东宣示其自身文化个性（几乎达到了神一般的形象）的最高峰，也就是绝对的最后巅峰。但这并不是在20世纪60年代才开始的。它真正始于20世纪40年代一个被称为整风运动的时期。当时，那些想要加入并成为共产主义革命一部分的追随者们，被迫接受了一项培训计划。在这个过程中，他们在心理上承受了极大的压力以融入党内，同时还被迫阅读了一系列精选书籍。在22本核心读物中，有18本是毛泽东的作品。换句话说，他极大地将他自己的思想，而不仅仅是共产主义的普遍思想，
at the center of the project. And for people who had gone through that process over, you know, on and off something like 20 years, simply moving someone of that level of standing out of the way it was not like basically kind of moving a middle manager or even the kind of senior ceo of an executive position out to a kind of honorary chairmanship this is very like how i and a lot of listeners feel about tom holland in this podcast yes tom holland thought well i i'm not going to want to pull down the statue of chairman tom i think i'm not worthy of that but but but run i mean basically so it's Marxism. So you can't get rid of Marx.
置于整个项目的中心。对于那些断断续续经历了大约20年这种过程的人来说，要把一个处于那种地位级别的人移开，可不像把一个中层经理，甚至不像把高级执行官职位的高级CEO换成荣誉董事长那样简单。这非常像我和许多听众对这个播客中的汤姆·霍兰的看法。是的，汤姆·霍兰想，好吧——我可不想去推倒毛主席的雕像，我觉得自己不配那样做——但是，拉纳，我的意思是，基本上这就是马克思主义，所以你无法摆脱马克思；
Leninism, you can't get rid of Lenin. And Mao Zedong thought, and therefore you can't get rid of Mao Zedong. And so that's a kind of the package that has been sold to the Chinese. Is that right? It is very much the package that's been sold to the Chinese, but it's worth remembering what Maoism is. And someone else who I hope if you haven't already done, you'll have on the podcast at some point, Tom, is the wonderful historian Julia Lovell, whose recent book on Maoism makes a really strong point about Mao's thought, which is that it's not definable, not quite in the way that Marx is, to particular books or particular texts, quite as a smorgasbord. I think that's probably a bit too Scandinavian for it,
列宁主义，你无法摆脱列宁；毛泽东思想，因此你无法摆脱毛泽东。所以这是向中国人兜售的一整套东西，是这样吗？这确实是向中国人兜售的一整套东西，但值得记住的是，究竟什么是毛泽东思想。还有另一位历史学家——如果你还没邀请过的话，我希望你能在某个时候请她上播客，汤姆——她就是杰出的历史学家朱莉娅·洛弗尔（Julia Lovell）。她最近关于毛泽东思想的书对毛泽东的思想提出了一个非常强有力的观点，那就是它无法被明确定义——不像马克思那样可以归结为特定的书籍或特定的文本，它更像是一个什锦拼盘。我想这个比喻可能过于斯堪的纳维亚风格了，
but maybe some kind of dim sum menu of a particularly kind of fiery, chilly-flavored sort. In other words, there are different things that make up what Maoism is. Yes, it's about peasant revolution. That's the thing that people tend to think of, I think. Yes, it's about the use of armed guerrilla tactics to overcome your enemy. But it's also about certain philosophical ideas, such as the glorification of violent renewal. In other words, the use of violent
不过或许更像是一份带有强烈辣椒风味的特色点心菜单吧。换句话说，构成毛泽东思想的是各种不同的东西。是的，它关乎农民革命，这通常是人们首先想到的方面。是的，它关乎利用武装游击战术来战胜敌人。但它也关乎某些哲学思想，比如对暴力重生的美化。换句话说，将暴力变革作为其自身的一种积极的善加以运用。他之所以喜欢这一点的一个原因，不仅仅是因为我认为他在看到事物被颠覆时获得了一种快感，还因为他强烈反对的儒家哲学传统，更多的是关于闲适、关于做学问、在许多意义上关于温和。而他想要提出一种排斥这些原则的哲学。
change as a positive good in its own right. One of the reasons he liked that was not just because actually he took a certain joy, I think, in seeing things being overturned, but also because the Confucian philosophical tradition against which he was reacting very strongly was much more about being sort of laid back, about being scholarly, about being kind of gentle in many senses. And he wanted to put forward a philosophy which rejected those principles. And that drove him for much of his life. And so that's the famous political power growing out of the barrel of a gun. Well, that phrase about the gun in some ways does bring up that idea of violent change. In fact, the second half of that sentence is also worth noting, which is that is why the party elite and the revolutionaries who have done that come to constitute another elite. I mean, is that the issue that he's kind of focusing in on? It is. And it isn't, of course, the only occasion that happened. The Yugoslav Marxist theorist, Gilas, was the man who thought up the idea of the new class.
这驱动了他的大部分人生。所以这就是那句名言：“枪杆子里面出政权”。嗯，关于枪杆子的那句话在某种程度上确实唤起了暴力变革的概念。事实上，这句话的后半句也值得注意，那就是为什么党内精英和完成这一切的革命者最终构成了另一批精英。我的意思是，这正是他所关注的问题所在吗？正是如此。当然，这并不是唯一一次发生这种情况的事情。南斯拉夫马克思主义理论家吉拉斯（Đilas）提出了“新阶级”的概念。
In other words, the communist bureaucrats who get so far ahead in the system, they really like a sort of new bourgeoisie. And in this particular case, Mao, I think, had a very similar idea. He referred, for instance, to the health ministry, which he felt was dealing purely with the needs of urban dwellers and not nearly enough about the peasantry by referring to it as not the ministry of health, but the ministry of urban gentleman's health, thereby sort of giving them, you know, a rather sort of a scornful eyebrow in terms of who they're actually looking at. And that led, of course, the policy that you probably will remember of barefoot doctors, in other words, peasants who are given very basic medical training and then made to go out to the countryside in an attempt to break down this idea of the health service
换句话说，共产主义官僚在体制内爬得太高，他们真的很像一种新资产阶级。而在特定情况下，我认为毛泽东也有非常相似的想法。例如，他曾把卫生部称为“城市老爷卫生部”，而不是卫生部，因为他觉得卫生部纯粹在处理城市居民的需求，而对农民的需求关注远远不够。通过这种方式，他在他们究竟关注谁的问题上，向他们投去了充满轻蔑的一瞥。这当然导致了你可能还记得的“赤脚医生”政策——换句话说，让接受了非常基础医学培训的农民深入农村，试图打破卫生服务
purely being the preserve of bureaucratic elites. I don't know whether Andrew Lansley or one of the members of the UK might have thought of barefoot doctors as a solution to the problem there, but certainly it was on Mao's mind. And as a result, because of what he would have seen as the bourgeoisification, if that's the right word, of the revolution 17 years in, he also, this is one of the most curious things about the Cultural Revolution, when he decided to inspire large parts of society to rise up against it, he was actually able to get an awful lot of adherence from people who had been sidelined in the previous 17 years. But many of those were
纯粹由官僚精英垄断的观念。我不知道安德鲁·兰斯利（Andrew Lansley）或英国的某位成员是否曾将赤脚医生视为解决该问题的方法，但毛泽东脑子里确实有这个想法。正因如此，由于他认为革命在进行了17年后已经“资产阶级化”（如果这是个恰当的词的话），这也是文化大革命最奇特的地方之一：当他决定激励社会的大部分阶层起来反抗这种状况时，他实际上能够从在过去17年中被边缘化的人群中获得大量的追随者。但其中许多人
actually people who came from what were known as bad class backgrounds. In other words, if you're actually a bourgeois from the old society, you might have been so badly treated in the 17 years of the communist revolution that you would actually find yourself being on the front lines for the cultural revolution. So what goes around comes around exactly so so one last question before we get into the sort of narrative the cultural revolution um this is obviously the age of the sino-soviet split um and china is isolated uh russia is the soviet union rather is sort of moving slowly towards detente um particularly when nixon in in January 1969. Do you think the Cultural Revolution is also driven by a kind of paranoia about encirclement abroad and, you know, that the
实际上来自所谓的“不好阶级成分”。换句话说，如果你在旧社会里实际上是个资产阶级，你在共产主义革命的17年里可能受到了恶劣的对待，以至于你可能会发现自己冲在了文化大革命的最前线。所以这叫风水轮流转，完全是这样。因此，在进入文化大革命的叙事之前，最后一个问题——这显然是中苏分裂的时代，中国处于孤立状态，俄罗斯——或者说苏联——正在缓慢走向缓和，特别是在1969年1月尼克松（访华前夕）。你认为文化大革命也是由一种对外部包围的偏执所驱动的吗？比如苏联已经背离了真正的共产主义道路等等？我的意思是，是否存在对遭受攻击的真正恐惧？文化大革命是中国历史上最仇外的时期之一。在这个时期，几乎任何与外国属性的联系——无论是懂一门外语，还是穿着被视为外国风格的衣服（而且正如你所指出的，多米尼克，这种外国既可以指苏联，也可以指美国，因为中苏分裂意味着北京确实有苏联外交存在，但处理得非常、非常冷淡）——都成了禁忌。在这种情况下，与外国人的任何接触在政治上都是危险的，这绝对是当时氛围的一部分。
Soviets have left the true path of communism and all that sort of thing? I mean, is there a genuine fear of attack and stuff? The Cultural Revolution is one of the single most xenophobic periods of Chinese history. It's a period when almost any association with foreignness, whether it's knowing a foreign language or wearing clothes that are perceived to be foreign, and foreign could be Soviet, as you pointed out, Dominic, as well as American in that case, because of course, the Sino-Soviet split meant that there was a Russian diplomatic presence or a Soviet diplomatic presence in Beijing, but it was very, very coldly handled. And in that case, it was certainly very, very much part of the atmosphere that any involvement with foreigners was politically dangerous. And as a result, the fear of
因此，对外国人的恐惧以及他们理论上可能对中国做的事，也成了当时政治语言的一部分。所以，美国支持的世界充满敌意、只要被允许进入中国就随时准备摧毁共产主义这种想法，是其中很大的一部分。但实际上，到那个阶段——即60年代中期，苏联才是真正要进攻中国的恐惧，在至少一部分领导人的心中已经变成了压倒一切的恐惧。当然，正如我们可能会谈到的那样，这最终导致了在文化大革命进行到一半时与美国的缓和。但这在文革开始之前显然并不明显。
foreigners and what they might be, at least in theory, going to do to China became part of the political language of the time as well. So the idea that, you know, certainly the American backed world was hostile and just waiting to destroy communism if they were allowed into China was a large part of it. But actually, by that stage, by the mid 60s, the fear that it was the Soviet Union that was in fact going to attack China had become a really overwhelming fear in the minds of at least some of the leadership. And that, of course, eventually, as we'll probably touch upon, leads to a repression with America halfway through the Cultural Revolution. But that certainly wasn't obvious before it had even begun. So, Rana, the actual events in the Cultural Revolution, it's signalled in a kind of strange
所以，拉纳，关于文化大革命的具体事件，它以一种奇怪的方式由毛泽东在长江中游泳拉开了序幕。那到底是怎么回事呢？这就是毛泽东本人在他人生的很大一部分时间里，将体育锻炼作为发出政治信号的一种手段。这部分是因为对他产生影响的诸多因素：马克思主义、中国传统哲学，以及当时所谓的粉丝同人小说式的作品，比如《水浒传》这类经典的中国侠义小说。
way by Mao going for a swim in the Yangtze. So what is going on there? So this is what Mao himself actually, through much of his life, used physical exercise as a means of sending a political signal. And this was partly because of the many influences on him, Marxism, Chinese traditional philosophy, the kind of sort of what you might call fanfic novels at the time, you know, the Outlaws of the Marsh, these classic Chinese novels of Daring Do.
他读过所有这些书，并且都非常热爱。但其中一个特定的影响——这实际上是20世纪整个东亚哲学的一个巨大因素——就是社会达尔文主义。换句话说，这种现在显然已被完全彻底否认的观点，即种族之间相互竞争的方式就像物种在进化中相互竞争一样。毛泽东基本上接受了这一点，就像当时许多知识分子一样，非常、非常强烈地接受了这一点，因此他决定，个人层面的体力是表明
He read all of those, loved all of those. But one particular influence, which actually was a very big factor in East Asian philosophy in general in the 20th century, was social Darwinism. In other words, this now obviously completely discredited idea that somehow races compete with each other in the way that the species compete with each other in terms of evolution. And Mao basically bought this, as many intellectuals at the time did, very, very strongly and therefore decided that physical strength on a personal basis was a really important way of indicating
你对国家的态度以及一般情况下国家如何武装自己以抵御外部侵略者的一种非常重要的方式。你们觉得是否有任何——我确信不会是这样——人到中年的发福迹象出现在你们两个身上，多米尼克或汤姆，无论你们在哪里。事实上，从视频里我能看到你们穿的运动上衣，所以我有点好奇那里是不是有些什么情况。
both how you felt towards your country and how, in general, how countries could arm themselves against outside occupiers. Should you feel that there's any kind of, I'm sure it wouldn't be the case, but middle-aged spread appearing, either Dominic or Tom, where you are. I can see your tracky top from where I have on the video, actually, so I'm wondering whether there might be something there.
你可能会觉得，不如去尝试一下毛主席的个人锻炼计划。他在文革前很早就在全集里写下的作为书面作品之一的最早内容中，我今天就不给你讲全部内容了，但我们只能说，它涉及大量的上下蹲起，而且臀部推力也很精彩。我不会现在就在播客里做这个动作。我必须说，如果文化大革命是以一些深蹲和臀部推力开始的，那在各方面都会更加迷人。但正如你所说，实际上，去长江游泳作为一种力量展示，是开始时的信号之一。
You might feel worse than try out the Chairman Mao personal exercise plan. One of the first things the first things that he actually wrote down that we have as one of his written works which is in the in the complete works very early on before he became a marxist i won't give you the full thing now but let's just say it involves a lot of up and down squats and and and buttock thrusts are also brilliant as well i'm not gonna do it on the podcast now i have to say that had the cultural revolution started with a bit of squatting and thrusting that would have been even more fascinating in various ways. But as you say, it was actually going for a swim in the Yangtze as a kind of show of strength was one of the signals at the beginning.
除此之外，还有其他一些事情，回想起来，你可以看出风向所在。所以还有一个实际的项目，在正常情况下可能不会被视为一个特别重要的元素，那就是一篇戏剧评论。我的意思是，我们通常期望戏剧版块夹在报纸的第二部分，你为什么要在乎那个呢？但在这种情况下，由剧作家兼学者吴晗创作的一部名为《海瑞罢官》的历史剧。这基本上是一个隐喻，但它是一个源自几百年前明朝的故事，讲述了一个被撤职的正直官员。毛泽东身边的许多人认为这被用作了一个——正如它很可能的那样——
Along with a few other things that in retrospect, you can see, you know, the wind, the direction the wind was going. So one actual other item, which might not in normal terms seem to be a particularly important element, was a theatre review. I mean, you know, we normally expect the kind of theatre pages are stuck in the second part of the newspaper, and why would you care about that? But in this case, a play by the playwright and scholar Wu Han, which was called Hai Wei Dismissed from Office. And this was basically from a metaphor, but it was a story dating from the Ming dynasty hundreds of years before about a righteous official who had been sacked from his job. And various people around Mao thought that this was being used, as it probably was,
对一个更近事件的类比，那个事件就是在可怕的大跃进期间，解雇了当时的国防部长彭德怀。彭德怀是一位伟大的共产主义将领，在战场上极其出色，但他敢于向权力说真话。他向毛泽东讲述了农村的饥荒情况，结果被基本上开除了公职。因此，这部戏及其演出基本上被视为对毛泽东的一记挖苦，随后出现了一篇对这部戏的官方评论，这几乎可以归咎于毛泽东及其派系，他们宣称：
as an analogy for a much more recent event, which was during the terrifying Great Leap Forward, the firing of the then Defence Minister Peng Dehuai, great communist general, brilliant on the battlefield, but he had dared to speak truth to power. He had told Mao about the starvation in the countryside and as a result was basically kicked out of office. So this play, its performance, was basically seen as a dig at Mao and an official review appeared of this play, which was pretty much attributed to Mao and his factions saying,
怎么会有什么反革命分子为这个被正确撤职的官员鸣不平。所以我们可以看到，这种深深的怨恨情绪开始在毛泽东对中国媒体和宣传机器有一定控制的领域中浮现出来。那么，你如何从一个人去游泳、一篇戏剧评论，演变成一大群人冲出来——关闭理发店、拔掉花坛？我的意思是，这不仅仅是那样，汤姆。我知道，但是那种最初的“我们必须清除四旧”的所有那些东西，因为这发生得相当快，不是吗？这确实发生得
how dare some counter-revolutionary make this case for an official who has been rightly dismissed from his post. So we could see that this sense of deep resentment was beginning to emerge in the areas where Mao had some control over the media and the propaganda machinery in China. So how do you go from a guy having a swim and a theatre review to loads of people rushing around um closing down barber shops and pulling up flower beds i mean it's more than that tom i mean that's pretty i know but but but but that kind of initial we've got to get rid of all the four olds all that kind of stuff because it happens quite quickly doesn't it it does happen
很快。因此，我认为需要了解的第一件事是，据我们所知，当毛泽东发动文化大革命时，他并不知道自己正在发动文化大革命。我的意思是，他并不知道自己即将开启后来长达十年的非凡动荡、政治暴力、对生命财产以及遗产等等的破坏。最初，它本意只是给一些学生的一个暑期项目。就我个人而言，我宁愿把他们送去参加什么爱丁堡公爵野营计划之类的，但他有不同的想法。换句话说，我们之前谈到的情绪——即革命正在失去火种、需要年轻人来更新它的想法，我们谈论的是20世纪60年代。
quickly so the very first thing i think to be aware of, as far as we can tell, is that when Mao started the Cultural Revolution, he didn't know he was starting the Cultural Revolution, by which I mean, he didn't know he was about to launch what turned out to be 10 years of extraordinary turmoil, political violence, destruction of lives and property and, you know, heritage and all of these things. Originally, it was meant to be a summer project for some students. I mean, personally, I'd rather just send them off to kind of, you know, Duke of Edinburgh camp or whatever, but he had different ideas. In other words, the sentiment that we talked about before, the idea that the revolution is losing its fire, and it's the young people who need to renew it. And, you know, we're talking
我的意思是，几年后的1968年巴黎，就出现了类似情绪的一种截然不同的表现：青年不知为何是社会中最激进的部分，他们必须起来反抗长辈以使社会变得更好。中国案例的不同之处在于，除了它发生得早几年这一事实之外，是中共中央主席实际上在从底层动摇整个局势。
about the 1960s here. I mean, 1968 in Paris, just a couple of years later, saw a very different manifestation of a similar sort of sentiment that somehow the youth were the most radical part of society and they had to rise up against their elders to make society better. The difference in the case of China, apart from the fact it's happening a couple of years earlier, is that it's the chairman of the Chinese Communist Party who's actually essentially shaking the situation up from the bottom.
所以他的想法是，如果我们基本上能让中国的青年，特别是受过教育的青年、大学和高中的学生在夏天出来，开始对那些自以为知道自己在做什么、自以为一切都想明白了但实际上需要接受教训的社会高级长辈和所谓上级进行物理或言语上的攻击，那对于我自己——毛泽东为重新获得高层领导权而展开的运动来说，将是一个很好的软化。这个想法是，学生们在夏天做这件事，然后在秋天回到学校。所以它应该是一个只持续几周、
So his thought was, if we can basically get China's youth, particularly the educated youth, the students in universities and high schools to come out over the summer and basically start attacking, whether physically or verbally, the seniors and supposed superiors in society who think they know what they're doing, who think they've got it all worked out, but actually need to be taught a lesson, that will be a good softening up in terms of my own Mao's campaign for regaining a level of power within the top leadership. And the idea was that the students would do this over the summer, and then they go back to school in the autumn period. So it would be something that basically lasted a few weeks,
甚至几个月的事情。我想，没有人会比毛泽东本人更惊讶了，当整件事情证明其背后有着如此汹涌的怒火，将它推向了一个甚至连他自己恐怕也未曾料到的高度。所以它从小处着手，但随后迅速壮大。这就引发了一个非常有趣的问题：就像许多革命或许多运动一样，
maybe even a few months. And nobody, I think, was as surprised as Mao himself when the whole thing turned out to have this huge raging fire behind it that took it to a level beyond what I think even he himself would have expected. So it started small, but then became large very quickly. Well, that then raises a really interesting question because like so many revolutions or so many movements,
总是有这样一种——我的意思是，这是一个非常高级别的A-level考题式的问题，我想——它是自上而下的，还是自下而上的？显然这里面存在一种张力，但它自下而上的性质——学生们将事情掌握在自己手中，但我想在另一个层面上，你会谈到地方精英或地方团体将事情掌握在自己手中，也许不受中央指挥。在18岁年轻人的头脑或经历中，究竟是什么成分驱动他们陷入这种——我讨厌听起来像是在中档大众报纸上写专栏，但这群暴力狂欢——我的意思是，这究竟是从哪里来的？这不仅仅是因为他们被告知要这样做，对吧？当然——我们要谈谈英国销量最大的报纸，我想“人民的敌人”这个词，那是文化大革命还是大众报纸？不，无论如何，我们不扯远了，我们不扯远了，我们刚开始播客时，如果你不相信——当然，文化大革命的一个特点就是不守规矩绝对是其中的核心，因为其中一个主要点
there is always this, I mean, it's such a sort of A-level question, I suppose. Is it top-down or is it bottom-up? And obviously, there's a tension, but the bottom-up nature of it, so the students, you know, taking things into their own hands, but I suppose on a different level, you would talk about local elites or local groups taking things into their own hand maybe not directed by the center how much when what is there what are the ingredients you know what is it in in in 18 year olds minds or experiences that drives them into this you know i hate to sound like um writing a column in a mid-market newspaper but this orgy of violence i mean where does that come from it's not just because they're told to right surely we'll talk about britain's biggest selling newspaper i think the words that the words are most beloved newspaper full of much-loved columnists absolutely just remember the phrase enemies of the people was that cultural revolution or a mid-market no anyway we won't go down there we won't go down there we kicked off the podcast if you don't believe absolutely well of course one of the things about the cultural revolution of course was misbehavior was absolutely the center of it because one of the major points
就是它给了人们一个反抗权威的机会。所以，多米尼克，为了回答你的问题，关于是什么激励了18岁、也许还有17岁和16岁的年轻人：当国家的统治者告诉他们，你必须做的最重要的事情，就是去对那些自认为高人一等、懂得比你多、可以对你指手画脚的人——包括他们的老师，对吧？特别是他们的老师，绝对是他们的老师——或是按毛泽东的说法，政治局的其他成员。我的意思是，同样的观点在截然不同的层面上被应用，换句话说，过去17年（自1949年以来）建立起来的权威结构
was that it gave people a chance to kick back against authority so in answer to your question dominic about you know what is it that motivates 18 year olds and maybe 17 year olds and 16 year olds too being told by the ruler of the country that the most important thing you have to do is tell all the people who think they're so superior they know more than you they can tell including their teachers right especially their teachers particularly their teachers absolutely or in the case of Mao other members of the Politburo I mean the same point is being used at a rather different level that in other words the structures of authority that have built up over the last one of 17 years at that
必须被推翻，这就是动力。然后，如果你考虑在基层，究竟是什么在激励人们反抗，想想所有那些本质上激发——你知道，任何社会中的大多数人，在更贫困的社会阶层中，有的人觉得革命并没有给他们带来好 deal（待遇）。你知道，他们以为生活会改变，但实际上并没有改变多少。他们没有得到那份更好的工作，也没有得到工厂工头的职位。有太多的理由让他们感到怨恨。
point since 1949 have to be overturned that's's the motivation. And then if you think about at the grassroots, what it is that might motivate people to rebel, think about all the things that essentially animate, you know, most people in any society, in the more impoverished parts of society, there were people who felt that the revolution hadn't given them a good deal. You know, they thought that life was going to change and actually didn't change all that much. They didn't get that better job or they didn't get the factory foreman's position. Lots of reasons to be resentful
1949年以来的各项成果都必须被推翻，这就是动机。再想想基层，到底是什么在激励人们去反叛呢？想想那些基本上能调动任何社会中大多数人积极性的事情吧。在社会较为贫困的阶层里，有些人觉得革命并没有给他们带来什么好结果。你知道，他们以为生活会发生改变，但实际上并没有改变多少。他们没有得到更好的工作，也没有当上工厂工头。有很多理由让人心生怨恨。
against the next level of the elite above you in that particular case. Beyond that, you also have the very long lasting existing fissures in society. Let me give you one example. It's one that's always fascinated me. And it's one that's sort of hard to pin down because it involves talking about things that people are very um sensitive about it in china but you know since we're not in china i will
对抗在这个特定情况下你头顶上的下一级精英。除此之外，社会中还存在着非常长久且根深蒂固的裂痕。我给你举个例子。这个例子一直让我着迷。而且它有点难以确切说明，因为它涉及到谈论人们在、嗯，在中国非常敏感的事情，但你知道，既然我们不在中国，我就会
you know make the point more explicitly here so lots of people in uh let's say southwest china cities like chengdu chongqing down there in sichuan province um and surrounding had been associated with the predecessor party, the nationalist party, the Kuomintang, which Chiang Kai-shek had run until they were mostly kicked out to Taiwan in 1949. But of course, the vast majority of Chinese who had supported the Kuomintang
你知道，在这里更明确地指出这一点：所以在中国西南部，比方说成都、重庆这些四川省的城市，以及周边地区的许多人，都曾与前政权、国民党有关联，蒋介石一直领导着这个党，直到他们在1949年大部被驱逐到台湾。但是当然，绝大多数支持国民党的中国人
did not get to go to Taiwan. That was about two or three million people who did that. But millions of others had to remain behind in China. And many of them essentially, you know, were treated very badly, not least because they were thought to come from bad class backgrounds, but it became a sort of hereditary thing. So, you know, you might be a former nationalist official and be treated badly, but it also meant that your kids would be treated badly and they would have grown up in high school, essentially at a level at which, you know, they
并没有去成台湾。当时大约有两三百万人生还并去了那里。但数以百万计的其他人不得不留在中国大陆。他们中的许多人基本上，你知道，受到了非常糟糕的对待，不仅因为他们被认为出身不好的阶层，而且这变成了一种世袭的东西。所以，你知道，你可能是个前国民党官员而遭到虐待，但这同时也意味着你的孩子也会遭到虐待，他们会在高中时就成长为这样一种人：基本上处于这样一个层面，即他们
would be regarded as a slightly alien, slightly not at the center of the project. So for those people being told at the age of 17, it's time to are pushing back against the social structures, actually came from class backgrounds that previously would have been regarded as dark or black or inappropriate in some ways. And the reasons for that was that there was this whole group of people, millions of them, who had very good reason to be resentful against the existing structure and were just looking for any excuse basically to overturn it. Students with their teachers, workers with their managers. How brutal is this process in the opening weeks of the Cultural Revolution? Some of the most brutal acts seen under the rule of Mao Zedong, and he saw plenty of brutal acts going on, took place during the first phase of the Cultural Revolution.
会被视为有点异类，有点并不处于核心工程之中。所以对这些人来说，在17岁时听到“是时候去反抗社会结构了”这种话，其实他们自身的阶级背景在以前某种程度上会被视为黑暗的、黑色的或不适当的。其原因在于，存在着这样一大群人，数以百万计，他们有充分的理由对现有结构心怀怨恨，并且基本上只是在寻找任何借口来推翻它。学生对老师，工人对管理者。文化大革命初期的这个过程究竟有多残暴？毛泽东统治下见证的一些最残暴的行为——而他见证过大量残暴的行为——发生在文化大革命的第一阶段。
The one that perhaps has become the most famous is what's known as the airplane position, because it basically involves being paraded if you were a teacher or a bureaucrat or someone who's regarded as needing to be cut down to size in front of a probably screaming crowd of people who you'd previously been in control of. Could be school children, could be factory workers, whatever. And a group of such people would be forced to stand on a stage. They might have signs placed around their neck saying, you know, I'm a bourgeois backslider. I'm a snake demon. I'm a cow demon. One of these rather superstitious sounding terms that actually were used to attack people during that time. But they were then forced to stand with their hands outstretched to their full length.
其中也许最出名的被称为“飞机式”，因为它基本上涉及如果你是一名老师、官僚，或者某个被认为需要受到沉重打击的人，就要被拉出来游街示众，面对一群很可能是你以前管辖过、现在却在大喊大叫的群众。可能是小学生，可能是工厂工人，什么都行。而这样一群人会被强迫站在一个舞台上。他们的脖子上可能会挂着牌子，写着，你知道，“我是资产阶级回潮派”、“我是牛鬼”、“我是蛇神”。这些听起来相当迷信的术语，在那个时期实际上被用来攻击人们。但随后他们被迫双臂向两侧完全伸展地站着，
So looking a little bit like a kind of mascot of an airplane. And if you try doing that, I mean, you know, if you try this at home, don't try it for very long, because it's a very, very painful position to be in. Obviously, it's fine if you start to get a bit sore, and you can just sit down and rub your arms. But if you're being forced to stand there for hours and hours on end, while people are screaming at you and shouting at you and telling you're the worst person in the world, while you're unable to move or basically wriggle at all. It's an absolutely torturous position to be in. And the airplane position became one of the best known forms of torture.
所以看起来有点像飞机的吉祥物。如果你试着这样做，我的意思是，你知道，如果你在家里尝试这个，千万不要坚持太久，因为这是一个非常非常痛苦的姿势。很显然，如果你开始感到酸痛，那没关系，你可以坐下来揉揉胳膊。但如果你被迫一连几个小时站在那里，周围的人对你大喊大叫、冲你怒吼，说你是世界上最糟糕的人，而你却根本不能移动或扭动身体。这绝对是一个折磨人的姿势。而“飞机式”成了最臭名昭著的酷刑形式之一。
I think there's no reason to avoid that term in terms of how the lessons, the revisionist lessons were supposed to be taught to these teachers and bureaucrats and others in society who needed to be re-educated. Right. I think that, I mean, that's a kind of unsettling and menacing moment, which we should perhaps take a break for a bit of capitalism. And when you've had your days of capitalism, please come back and we will plunge into the absolute more of the cultural revolution. We'll see you back in a few minutes. and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. What stinks is not so much the excrement as your own ideology. That was the red guards to cleaners at Beijing University who complained having to clean up after the huge
我认为没有理由在如何向这些需要被重新教育的老师、官僚和社群中的其他人传授这些修正主义教训时回避这个词。对。我认为，我的意思是，这是一个令人不安且充满威胁的时刻，也许我们应该休息一下，谈谈资本主义。当你过完你的资本主义日子后，请回来，我们将一头扎进文化大革命的绝对泥潭中。几分钟后见。想要获取现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。令人恶心的与其说是排泄物，不如说是你自己的意识形态。这是红卫兵对北京大学清洁工说的话，清洁工抱怨不得不清理海量的
numbers of students who had flocked to Beijing on the invitation of Chairman Mao and the sheer volume of excrement deposited into the university toilets had made them all seize up. And Rana, you talked earlier, you made allusion to the Duke of Edinburgh scheme. An obvious connection there, Tom, clearly, yeah. Well, there is a slight sense in which, for students, this is all, I mean, huge fun, because in the early weeks of the Cultural Revolution, Mao basically issues an invitation, doesn't he, to students from across China to come to Beijing. And he's astounded by how many turn up. About a million people. Is it, Rana, is that an exaggeration?
应毛主席邀请蜂拥来到北京的学生们，大量排泄物倒入大学厕所，导致厕所全部堵塞。雷娜，你刚才谈到了，你提到了爱丁堡公爵奖。汤姆，这之间显然有着显而易见的联系，是的。嗯，在某种微弱的意义上，对学生来说，这一切，我的意思是，简直是天大的乐趣，因为在文革初期，毛主席基本上发出邀请，不是吗，邀请全中国的学生来北京。而他对出现的人数之多感到震惊。大约有一百万人。是这样吗，雷娜，这是一种夸张吗？
No, it's more than that over time. It's a million who can fit at its height into Tiananmen Square in the centre of Beijing, managed to get them in the corners and the side streets and so forth as well. But no, it's an absolutely astonishing phenomenon. By the way, that notice about needing to clean up the excrement, I guess if it would turn into a Western band, it would be called Rage Against the Latrine. Oh, very good. Very good. Very good. Just thought I had to get that one in there. There's a chapter title waiting to be written. I have to say, Chairman Mao dearly loved a poo joke. He was very, very keen on fecal humor and used it extensively, just also throwing that in there. There's a phenomenon called chuanlian it literally just means exchange but for people who are now in china in let's say their 60s 70s 80s
不，随着时间的推移，人数更多。这是一百万能够挤进北京中心天安门广场的人数顶峰，他们还设法挤进了各个角落、小巷等等。但不是的，这绝对是一个令人震惊的现象。顺便说一句，关于需要清理排泄物的那个通知，我想如果把它变成一支西方乐队，它可能会被称为“愤怒对抗厕所”。哦，太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。我只是觉得我得把这个梗塞进去。这里有一个等待被书写的章节标题。我必须说，毛主席非常喜欢大便笑话。他非常非常热衷于粪便幽默，并广泛地使用它，我也顺便把它扔在这里。有一个现象叫“串联”，它字面上的意思就是交流，但对于现在中国的那些，比方说60多岁、70多岁、80多岁的人来说，
in other words people who were teenagers or relatively you know young men and women during the cultural revolution this phenomenon truanlian exchange is probably the thing that they remember most strongly if they weren't persecuted because it was basically the first chance that many of these young people had to essentially not not exactly see the world but to see china and to talk to each other train travel was made free for them throughout china during the period the cultural revolution it was like basically the world's most ideological interrail pass i'm showing my age by talking about interrail because as uh someone pointed out to me the other day, these days, young people fly, assuming they're actually
换句话说，在文化大革命期间是青少年或相对年轻的男女的人，如果你没有受到迫害的话，“串联”这种交流现象可能是他们记忆最深刻的事情，因为这基本上是这些年轻人中的许多人第一次有机会，基本上不是说去见识世界，而是去看看中国，并互相交谈。在文革期间，全中国的火车旅行对他们来说都是免费的，这基本上就像是世界上最具意识形态色彩的欧洲火车通票（Interrail pass）。我说出“Interrail”暴露了我的年龄，因为正如有人前几天向我指出的那样，如今的年轻人都是坐飞机的，假设他们实际上
allowed to travel anywhere. But essentially, you know, China's youth were given this free pass to get on trains, and probably leave the toilets pretty horrific as well, if it came to that, and just basically hang out with each other. You know, they would eat and drink, they would meet people from all over the country. It was an astonishing experience. It was a chance for them to basically learn about who they were, who their revolutionary counterparts were. And then, of course, as a culmination, go up to Beijing, where they would essentially worship at the near godlike altar of Chairman Mao, Mao Zedong. And so these gatherings in hundreds of thousands of millions that you're talking about, Dominic, absolutely. On a regular basis, if you were really lucky, you would get into one of those mass rallies with Mao, perhaps this sort of very distant figure right at the end. You could see sort of waving, wearing, of course, a green Red Guard uniform in sympathy with the green drab uniforms that all of these young Red Guards were supposed to wear. And bearing
被允许去任何地方旅行的话。但本质上，你知道，中国的青年被赋予了这个免费通票去坐火车，如果真要说的话，可能也把厕所弄得一团糟，然后基本上就是聚在一起闲逛。你知道，他们会吃吃喝喝，他们会遇到来自全国各地的人。这是一次令人震惊的经历。这对他们来说是一个机会，基本上可以了解他们是谁，谁是他们的革命同龄人。然后，当然，作为高潮，前往北京，在那里他们基本上会在毛主席——毛泽东那近乎神一般的祭坛前顶礼膜拜。因此，多米尼克，你所谈论的成百上千万人的这些聚会，绝对是这样的。通常情况下，如果你真的非常幸运，你就能进入那些有毛主席参加群众集会，也许这是一个远在最前方的非常遥远的形象。你可以看到他一边挥手，一边穿着，当然是一身绿色的红卫兵制服，以此来同情所有这些年轻红卫兵都应该穿的草绿色制服。并且怀着
with this term, Red Guard, Hong Weibing, was the one that was generically used for all the sort of young people who became Chairman Mao's, you know, almost personal Red Guard. But the idea was also that it was a militarization of society. In other words, you had to think of yourself not as a student, not as a scholar, not as a shop worker, but as a soldier. And these young troops coming and gathering in the square at the heart of Beijing, they were transformed. It was a religious experience.
“红卫兵”（Hong Weibing）这个词，是用来泛指所有那些成为毛主席的，你知道，几乎是私人红卫兵的年轻人的统称。但这个想法也是为了实现社会的军事化。换句话说，你必须把自己当成一个士兵，而不是一个学生、一个学者、一个商店工人。而这些年轻的军队来到并聚集在北京核心的广场上，他们脱胎换骨了。那是一种宗教体验。
There's no other way to describe it. There's one amazing case recorded of a young man who goes to one of these rallies. He's so moved that he writes in his notebook, today, I saw Chairman Mao for the first time. I have changed my life to make today my birthday. In other words, that is a story of rebirth in an almost Christian sort of way,
没有别的词可以形容它。有一个被记录下来的惊人案例，一个年轻人去参加了其中一次集会。他深受感动，在笔记本里写道：今天，我第一次见到了毛主席。我改变了我的人生，将今天定为我的生日。换句话说，这是一个几乎以基督教方式重生的故事，
except obviously this theology is not Christian. Just on the worshipping, I mean, I know I'm jumping ahead by a couple of years, but I just wanted to read an extraordinary thing. So Mao was given 40 mangoes, wasn't he, in 1968 by the Pakistani foreign minister. And one of the mangoes was sent to the Beijing textile factory. And I'm just reading.
只不过很显然这种神学并不是基督教的。仅就崇拜而言，我的意思是，我知道我比原计划超前了好几年，但我只是想读一件非凡的事。所以1968年，巴基斯坦外长送给毛泽东40个芒果，对吧？其中一个芒果被送到了北京纺织厂。而我正在阅读。
Workers read out quotations from Mao and celebrated the gift. Altars were erected to display the fruit prominently. When the mango peel began to rot after a few days, the fruit was peeled and boiled in a pot of water. Workers then filed by and each was given a spoonful of mango water. And I could read much more about this mango business, creation of replicas of mangoes sent to factories around the country and so on. I mean, that's clearly a religious relic. And I'm just wondering, Tom will love this question,
工人们宣读毛主席语录并庆祝这份礼物。人们竖起祭坛，将这颗水果显眼地陈列出来。几天后芒果皮开始腐烂时，水果被剥皮并在水锅中煮沸。工人们随后排队走过，每人被分到了一勺芒果水。关于这个芒果的买卖，我还可以读很多，比如复制分发到全国各地工厂的芒果复制品等等。我的意思是，这显然是一个宗教圣物。我只是在想，汤姆会喜欢这个问题的，
so I thought I'd ask him instead of him to stop him talking. So Rana, how much is there a kind of religious impulse behind this? Because of course, the smashing of relics of the depraved, sinful old world, the erection of new gods, all of that. I mean, that feels very, you know, not just Protestant Reformation, but Akhenaten. It feels like something that is deeply rooted in human history. Look, Dominic, that's absolutely right. It's absolutely right. It's very, very religious in the way in which it manifests itself. And actually, one of the ways in which it's been very productive is for anthropologists who study religion, amongst other things. And that analysis of Mao's traveling
所以我决定问他而不是让他闭嘴别说了。所以雷娜，这背后有多少种宗教冲动？因为当然，对堕落、罪恶的旧世界圣物的砸毁，新神的竖立，所有这一切。我的意思是，这让人感觉非常，你知道，不仅是新教改革，还有阿肯那顿。这感觉像是深深植根于人类历史的东西。听着，多米尼克，完全正确。绝对正确。它在自身的表现方式上是非常非常宗教化的。事实上，它非常具有成效的一个领域是针对研究宗教等事物的民族学者。对毛泽东巡回
mangoes, as he puts it, is written brilliantly by the anthropologist Adam Chow, who I'd highly recommend if people want to read more about that particularly bizarre phenomenon of the holy mangoes of Mao and how they moved around China. But it's worth thinking for a second what kind of religion we're talking about here, because, of course, the religion of China, to quote Max Weber for a moment there, the sociologist, is a very syncretic thing. And many different aspects of that Chinese religious tradition come into this sort of Mao worship that we see in the Cultural Revolution. So first of all, there is a Christian element because, of course, Christian missionaries have been a very central presence to China ever since the mid 19th century. And of
芒果的分析，正如他所说的那样，由人类学家周思中（Adam Chau）进行了精彩的撰写。如果人们想更多地了解毛泽东圣芒果这一特别离奇的现象以及它们是如何在中国各地移动的，我强烈推荐他的作品。但值得花一秒钟思考一下我们在这里谈论的是哪种宗教，因为，当然，用社会学家马克斯·韦伯的一句话来说，中国的宗教是一个非常融合的实体。我们在文化大革命中看到的这种对毛泽东的崇拜，融入了中国传统宗教的许多不同方面。首先，存在着基督教元素，因为当然，自19世纪中叶以来，基督教传教士一直是存在于中国的一个非常核心的力量。而且
course, a much earlier revolution, the Taiping revolution of the late 19th century was based on, you know, essentially the delusions of a man who thought he was Jesus's younger brother in southern China. So that tradition of Christian millenarianism and kind of exuberant politics has a history there. But also these traditions go back in Buddhism as well. Buddhism, of course, is a religion, can be a religion of peace and nirvana and introspection, but it can also be a highly millenarian sort of enterprise, which at many points, certainly in the 18th and 19th century, gave opportunities essentially for politically radical groups to rise up and use the idea that, you know, the Queen Mother of the West was coming back and it was time to take up arms on her behalf as a means of mobilizing the wider population. And all those religious traditions sit in what is created in the Cultural Revolution. But one thing to add
当然，一场更早的革命，19世纪末的太平天国革命，是基于，你知道，本质上是一个在中国南方的、认为自己是耶稣弟弟的男人的妄想。因此，这种基督教千禧年主义和某种狂热政治的传统在那里有着一段历史。但这些传统也可以追溯到佛教。佛教当然是一种宗教，可以是一种关于平静、涅槃和内省的宗教，但它也可以是一种高度千禧年主义的企业，在许多节点上，肯定是在18和19世纪，它基本上为政治激进群体提供了崛起的机遇，并利用这样一种理念——即西王母即将归来，是时候以她的名义拿起武器了——作为动员更广泛民众的手段。所有这些宗教传统都存在于文化大革命所创造的东西中。但最后还要补充一点
finally to that, because I think it's important, again, in understanding the nature of the Cultural Revolution, you can't do any of these things unless you have some level of popular enthusiasm that wants to take it up. Early in the 20th century, you get various quite sterile political movements in China. There's a thing called the New Life Movement, which Chiang Kai-shek tries to implement. Not least, as you will know, Tom, because you wrote in one of your recent brilliant books, Chiang Kai-shek, of course, is the only Christian leader that China's ever had at the top level because he was a Methodist, as well as being Confucian and somewhat Buddhist, which was an interesting combination. And his attempt to try and have a sort of moral revival in 1930s China with what he called the New Life Movement, which has a very Christian feel to it, it was just a flop of highly political, ideological language and religious language, as we've been talking about, takes off like wildfire amongst the population. It's
最后要说明的是，因为我认为这很重要，在理解文化大革命的本质时，如果你没有任何层面的大众热情想要去承接它，你是无法完成任何这些事情的。在20世纪初，中国出现过各种相当死板的政治运动。有一项名为“新生活运动”的东西，蒋介石试图去推行它。正如你所知道的，汤姆，绝不仅仅是因为你在你最近的一本精彩著作中写过，蒋介石当然是中国历史上唯一达到最高层面的基督教领导人，因为他是一位卫理公会信徒，同时也是儒家信徒和某种程度上的佛教徒，这是一个有趣的组合。以及他在20世纪30年代的中国试图通过他所称的“新生活运动”来开展某种道德复兴的尝试，这带有非常浓厚的基督教色彩，结果却彻底失败了。正如我们一直在谈论的那样，高度的政治、意识形态语言和宗教语言在民众当中如野火般蔓延开来。它是
genuinely popular during that period. But it still seems strange to me. So we've got a couple of questions on this. We've got Hemingway, the cultural revolution seems so utterly radical. Is it unique to Chinese culture? And then Super Six asks the obvious question, was the Cultural Revolution change or continuity? Is there a tradition of such circumstances in China or elsewhere? And I hear what you're saying about Buddhism, and I hear what you're saying about Christianity. And of course, Marxism itself is very much in the kind of Christian tradition of apocalyptic demands for change and self-purification.
在那段时期是真正受欢迎的。但这对我来说仍然显得很奇怪。所以我们对此有一些问题。我们有海明威问：文化大革命看起来如此彻底地激进。这是中国文化所独有的吗？然后“超级六号”提出了一个显而易见的问题：文化大革命是变革还是延续？中国或其他地方是否有这种环境的传统？我听到了你对佛教的看法，也听到了你对基督教的看法。当然，马克思主义本身在很大程度上也属于基督教关于末世论变革和自我净化的传统。
So that's also clearly a crucial part of it. But still, China is a country that is fabulously ancient. Its civilization is one that has traditionally been rooted in respect for elders, for the inheritance of the classics. I don't speak Chinese, but from what I gather reading about Chinese, it's an incredibly subtle, nuanced language in which the blaring of slogans is quite alien to its traditions. Speaking as someone very ignorant of Chinese culture, but it does seem odd that China, of all the civilizations, should have produced this incredibly iconoclastic movement. Let me say two things off the back of that, Tom. The first is about the uniqueness or otherwise of the cultural revolution as a political phenomenon. And I think there is an argument, this should be said very, very carefully, because, you know, as historians, we all know that very few things are ever done for
所以这显然也是其中至关重要的一部分。但即便如此，中国是一个历史极其悠久的国家。它的文明传统上一直植根于对长辈的尊重、对经典传承的尊重。我不会说中文，但据我所了解到的关于中文的阅读来看，它是一种极其微妙、充满细微差别的语言，其中那种大肆宣扬的口号与它的传统大相径庭。作为一个对中国文化极其无知的人来说，中国竟然催生了这场令人难以置信的偶像破坏运动，这确实显得很奇怪。汤姆，针对这一点，我想说两点。第一点关于文化大革命作为一种政治现象的独特性与否。我认为存在着这样一种论点——这需要非常非常谨慎地说，因为，你知道，作为历史学家，我们都知道很少有什么事情是
the first time, even when they're done for the first time. But if you look at one of the great books on the subject, which is Mao's Last Revolution by Roderick Farquhar, the late Harvard scholar and Michael Schoenhaus, who's based in Sweden, you know, based on a fantastic weight of documentary experience. And pretty much on the first page, they argue that actually the Cultural Revolution is a unique phenomenon. No such phenomenon took place in any other communist society and probably not in any other society either, because it involves the overthrow of an existing bureaucratic communist order by the leader of that party against itself, so to speak. I mean, it's a very, very odd combination of circumstances. But having said that, I am going to mention a historical precedent, which I think does provide some of the reasons
第一次发生的，即使它们是第一次发生。但是如果你看看关于这个主题的伟大著作之一，那就是已故哈佛学者麦克法夸尔（Roderick Farquhar）和常驻瑞典的迈克尔·舒恩哈尔斯（Michael Schoenhals）合著的《毛泽东的最后革命》（Mao's Last Revolution），你知道，这是建立在惊人的文献经验分量之上的。而且几乎在第一页，他们就认为实际上文化大革命是一个独一无二的现象。在任何其他共产主义社会中都没有发生过这样的现象，而且可能在任何其他社会中也没有，因为它涉及到该党的领导人为了反对其自身，而推翻现有的官僚共产主义秩序，这么说吧。我的意思是，这是一个非常非常奇怪的环境组合。但话虽如此，我还是要提到一个历史先例，我认为它确实提供了一些原因，
that China, as opposed to any other country, as you rightly pointed out, should have this turn against its own past. And that comes from a phenomenon that actually Mao was very aware of, because it helped to make him in the early 20th century in China, that was the May 4th movement, named after a student demonstration that took place just outside, actually just outside the Forbidden City in the centre of Beijing, where Tiananmen Square now is, on 4th of May 1919. Now, I won't go into huge detail about this, I've written about it elsewhere. But essentially, it's a nationalist student demonstration that protests against China's weakness in the world at that point when it's being exploited by, as they put it, imperialists from outside and warlords
正如你正确指出那样，为什么中国而不是任何其他国家，会发生这种背叛自身过去的转变？这来自于一个实际上毛泽东非常清楚的现象，因为它帮助塑造了20世纪初的中国，那就是五四运动，它因一场学生示威而得名，这场示威就发生在外面，实际上就发生在现今北京中心天安门广场所在地、紫禁城外的外面，时间是1919年5月4日。现在，我不会对此展开冗长的细节，我在别处写过这些。但本质上，这是一场民族主义学生示威，抗议当时中国在世界上的软弱，当时中国正遭到他们所说的外部帝国主义者和内部军阀的剥削，
from inside, and instead advocated that, as they put it, Mr. Science and Mr. Democracy needed to come to China and basically transform it. And in that movement, in the May 4th movement and the associated new culture movement, you have a phenomenon in which a lot of China's young intellectuals, including Mao, who's very young at that time, look at their own past. They look at the philosophy of Confucianism. They look at the religious traditions of China. They look at what's come from China's past and say, what has this given us? We're sitting here in the early 20th century and we see that, you know, the British are selling opium all over the place. They, you know, foreigners are running riots in our country. The entire country, we came,
并主张他们所说的“赛先生”和“德先生”需要来到中国并基本上改造它。在这场运动中——在五四运动和相关的“新文化运动”中——你看到了这样一种现象：中国的大批年轻知识分子，包括当时非常年轻的毛泽东，都在审视自己的过去。他们审视儒家思想。他们审视中国的宗教传统。他们审视从中国过去流传下来的东西，并说：这给我们带来了什么？我们坐在这里，在20世纪初，我们看到，你知道，英国人在到处贩卖鸦片。他们，你知道，外国人在我们的国家横行霸道。整个国家，我们来，
you know, we overthrew the last emperor. We became a republic in 1912. And yet the entire country is driven by internal civil warfare. So why on earth should this Chinese tradition have anything to teach us? And as a result, and in contrast with other Asian nationalist societies at that time, such as, you know, the actions of Nehru and Gandhi in India, or the Meiji Restoration in Japan, China's intellectuals, in many cases, take the very radical path of deciding they're going to reject almost everything about their Confucian philosophical past. The great early 20th century writer Liu Xun basically wrote short stories accusing Confucianism of being the same as cannibalism, this really, really strong indictment. Now, all of this movement, the May
你知道，我们推翻了最后一个皇帝。我们在1912年成为一个共和国。然而整个国家却被内部的内战所驱使。那么中国传统凭什么能教给我们任何东西呢？因此，与当时其他亚洲民族主义社会（例如印度尼赫鲁和甘地的行动，或日本的明治维新）形成鲜明对比的是，中国的知识分子在许多情况下走了一条非常激进的道路，决定拒绝几乎所有关于儒家哲学的过去。20世纪初的伟大作家鲁迅基本上写短篇小说指责儒家思想等同于吃人，这是一种非常非常强烈的控诉。现在，所有这场运动，五四
4th movement, all of this anti-traditional, anti-Confucian thought would have been running around in the mind of Mao, who was fiercely, fiercely opposed to that tradition. And when you get to the Cultural Revolution 50 years later, at a time when Mao is in complete control of the country, having that sense that maybe the problem was not that the May 4th movement had rejected tradition, but it hadn't gone quite far enough in removing every single aspect of it, might have felt like the unfinished business
运动，所有这些反传统、反儒家的思想，一定都在毛泽东的脑海中盘旋，他坚决、坚决地反对这种传统。当你来到50年后的文化大革命时，在毛泽东完全控制国家的时期，这种感觉——也许问题不在于五四运动拒绝了传统，而在于它在根除每一个方面时还不够彻底——可能会让人觉得，这是50年前他在湖南省做一个年轻激进分子时尚未完成的事业。因此，本质上，正是中国文明的极端古老性，引发了对它的这种爆发性反应。在那些想要摧毁它的人的心中，答案是肯定的。如果你再想一想，回到毛泽东早期的著作，当他不是在写关于个人锻炼计划和骨盆前推必要性的文章时，他也写过一系列文章，非常、非常激烈地辩论和表达，
of 50 years previously when he was a young radical man in Hunan province. So essentially, it's the very antiquity of Chinese civilization that generates the kind of explosive reaction against it. In the minds of those who wanted to tear it down, the answer is yes. If you think about, again, going back to Mao's early writings, when he's not writing about sort of personal exercise plans and the need for buttock thrusts, he also wrote a series of essays, very, very kind of fiercely argued and felt,
关于一个名叫赵小姐的年轻女性，她基本上自杀了，因为她被迫接受了一场她不想要的婚姻。毛泽东使用了这样一个隐喻：当时的中国社会、儒家社会就像是一个无法打破的铁笼。我提到的作家鲁迅也使用过类似的隐喻，即铁屋子。但其核心思想是一样的。换句话说，传统的势力、
about a young woman called Miss Zhao, who basically took her own life because she was being forced into a marriage she didn't want to accept. And Mao used this metaphor of, you know, the Chinese society at the time, the Confucian society, being a sort of iron cage, which was impossible to break out of. Liu Shun, the writer I mentioned, used a similar sort of metaphor, the iron house. But the idea was the same. In other words, that the forces of tradition,
束缚着中国的过去的势力是如此强大——就像那个铁的隐喻一样——以至于你必须采取激进的行动，你必须打破它们，你必须熔化它们，你必须粉碎它们，它们不会仅仅因为你试图轻轻地扭动身子逃脱而让步。我认为这种心态解释了很多在最终演变成文化大革命的过程中所看到的愤怒和激进的拒绝。雷娜，你刚才用了这个词，我不知道你是不是故意用的，但你之前用了“吃人”这个词，我想举一些例子，所以，你知道，我们讨论了很多背后的思想，
the forces of the past that were binding China was so strong, I mean, iron as that metaphor, that you had to do something radical, you had to break them, you had to melt them, you had to smash them, they weren't going to simply give way because you sort of gently wiggled your way out and that mindset i think explains a lot of the anger and you know radical rejection that you see in what ultimately becomes the cultural revolution rana you mentioned use the word i don't know whether you used it deliberately but you used the word cannibalism earlier on and i wanted to give some so you know, we've talked a lot about the ideas behind it,
但那种赤裸裸的暴力。现在，我明白我们可能把很多年的跨度混为一谈成了一件事，这可能是错误的。但是，你知道，你有一个地方，我想，是不是广西，在那里发生了在我看来数量惊人的、作为文化大革命一部分的仪式性吃人事件？人们吃掉那些被贬为阶级敌人等身份的人的心脏、肝脏、生殖器，以及诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，这离北京很远。
but the sheer violence. Now, I know we're sort of conflating many years into a single thing, probably wrongly. But, you know, you have a place like, I think, is it Guangxi, where there is, what to my mind seems, a colossal amount of ritual cannibalism as part of the cultural revolution. People eating the hearts, the livers, the genitals of those who have been disgraced as identified as class enemies and all that sort of thing. I mean, this is a long way from Beijing.
它是讲究等级的，不是吗？高层革命者基本上能吃到心和肝，而工人们只能啄食一些腿部的残渣。这离北京很远。它在数英里之外的中国极南端。所以这似乎是某种自下而上的行为，对吧。那里到底发生了什么？究竟是什么解释了这种纯粹的……好吧，我可以理解，你知道，学生们喜欢他们可以去北京，他们可以坐火车旅行，他们可以去批判他们的老师。这一切在心理学上完全说得通。但暴力的纯粹残酷性，究竟是什么解释了这一点？那么，让我们先从吃人这个例子开始。
It's hierarchical, isn't it? That the top revolutionaries kind of get the heart and the liver and the workers just get to peck on bits of leg. And this is a long way from Beijing. It's hundreds of miles away in the far south of China. So that seems to be kind of bottom up, as it were. What's going on there? What explains the sheer... Okay, so I can understand, you know, students like the fact that they can go to Beijing, they can do train travel, they can have a go at their teachers. That all makes complete psychological sense. But the sheer ferocity of the violence, what explains that? So let's take the cannibalism example first.
正如你所说，广西省位于中国西南的远端。你所谈论的大部分证据似乎来自于一本名为《红色纪念碑》（Scarlet Memorial）的书，作者是一个匿名名为郑义的中国研究人员，出于充分的理由，我想他不想透露自己的真实姓名。我认为没有理由认为其中记录的至少一部分内容是不准确的。那里以及其他时期确实记录过人们参与极端行为的案例。值得注意的是，吃人作为一个概念，作为一个形象，在封建历史中深深植根于中国文化之中。每当你阅读历史记载，一直追溯到朝代历史，
Guangxi province, as you say, in the sort of far southwest of China. Much of the evidence that you're talking about comes from, I think, a book called Scarlet Memorial by this anonymously named Zheng Yi, a Chinese researcher who I think didn't, for good reasons, want to give his name. And I think there's no reason to think that at least some portion of what's written there is not accurate. There are certainly cases that have been recorded there and other times of people engaging in extreme behavior. It's worth noting that cannibalism as an idea, as ape is something that sits very very you know deeply in chinese culture whenever you read accounts you know way back into dynastic history
明代，甚至在此之前的宋代，当事情出了可怕的差错、混乱降临中国时，人们被迫或选择互相吞食的想法一再重现，作为人类最终陷入终极极端的形象。这些记录中有多少是字面意义上的，并不总是清楚，这并不意味着它们不是真的，但这同时也意味着人们必须明白它也具有文学色彩。但我认为更广泛的观点是一个重要的观点，首先你提到过，你提到的那个作者确实使用了吃人的隐喻，在他的案例中，实际上是指代儒家思想。而在这种情况下，当然，这是终极的反儒家思想。这也引出了
the ming dynasty and you know even before that song dynasty of when things had gone horribly wrong when chaos had come to china the idea that people have been forced to eat each other or chosen to eat each other recurs over and over again um as an image of humanity finally finding itself at its ultimate extreme how many of those are meant to be literal is not always clear doesn't mean that they're not but it does also mean that one has to sort of understand that it's sort of a literary as well but the wider point i think is is is an important one and first of all you mentioned that uh that you should the author i mentioned, did use the idea of cannibalism as a metaphor, in his case, actually, for Confucianism. In this case, of course, it's the ultimate anti-Confucianism. It does also bring
这样一个问题：人们是否会彼此做出极其非凡的暴力行为？关于这一点，我认为情况绝对是清晰的，而且毋庸置疑的。我举出的例子是，因为同样地，就其潜在结果而言，如果可以想象的话，它甚至更令人毛骨悚然，那就是，同样是在西南的一些城市里，当地青年闯入当地的军火库和军事基地并劫持坦克。基本上这些十几岁的青少年拥有了……哇，这是一场学生抗议。那是一场配备了所有弹药的学生抗议。在某些情况下，这基本上就是最终结果。
up the idea of do people commit utterly extraordinary acts of violence against each other? On that, I think, you know, the case is absolutely clear. And, you know, without any dispute. The example that I bring up, because again, in some ways, in terms of its potential outcome, it was almost more terrifying, if you can imagine such a thing, which was, again, in some of the cities of the Southwest, the local youth breaking into the local arsenal and the military barracks and hijacking tanks. And basically these sort of teenagers having... Wow, that is a student protest. That is a student protest, you know, with the ammunition all provided. And this was basically the end result in some case.
在另一些情况下，有一些证据表明，一些红卫兵决定去插手。再次联想到今天的乌克兰，决定闯入一个实验站，试图制造他们自己的核弹，这可能是一种非常具有爆炸性的方式——字面意义上的——来结束文化大革命。幸运的是，事情没有发展到那一步，但这个想法确实存在。因此，就人们真正把事情推向被认为是合理的边缘而言，文化大革命有大量的例子。
In another case, there's some evidence that some of the Red Guards decided to nip it. And again, in the shades of today in Ukraine, decided to nip into a kind of an experimental station and try and make their own nuclear bomb, which would have been perhaps a rather explosive way, literally, to end the Cultural Revolution. It didn't come to anything, fortunately, but the thought was there. So in terms of people really pushing away at the edge of what would have been considered reasonable, the Cultural Revolution has plenty of examples.
我们应该关注这一切是如何发展的，因为我们的时间快用完了。但本质上，另一件需要记住的事情是存在着多个派别。所以有我们讨论过的红卫兵，也就是学生。党内有各种派系，即共产党。然后还有军队，对吧？随后，军队基本上介入并从根本上改变了局面，利用文化大革命将中国转变为类似于军事独裁的东西。是这样吗？是的，大致如此。我的意思是，如果我们把文化大革命分阶段来看，第一阶段是1966年爆发到1969年，这是人们在新闻短片或照片中想到的经典阶段，红卫兵狂热和一切。绝对是毛泽东，你知道，在天安门广场接受尖叫的、崇拜的青少年的游行检阅。在毛泽东本人意识到
We should kind of look to how this plays itself out because we're running out of time. But essentially, the other thing to bear in mind is that there are multiple factions. So there are the Red Guards we've talked about, the students. There are various factions within the party, the Communist Party. And then there's the army, isn't there? And in due course, the army essentially steps in and basically transforms, uses the Cultural Revolution to transform China into something approximating to a military dictatorship. Is that right? Yes, that's broadly right. I mean, if we're going to periodize the Cultural Revolution, the first phase, 1966, when it breaks out to 1969, is the classic phase that people think of in newsreel or photographs, the red card screen and everything. Absolutely Mao, you know, receiving parades of screaming, you know, adoring teenagers in Tiananmen Square. That pretty much comes to an end after that, when Mao himself
三年这样的时间大概就够了，你知道，对社会的破坏，在那之后这基本上就结束了。正如你所说，一直非常支持所有这些行动、非常站在毛泽东一边的军队被请出来平息这一切。但随后这基本上让军队掌管了文化大革命。身处毛泽东身边的国防部长林彪负责执行此事。随后最高领导层内部发生了一种剧变。即使现在，我们也没有当时到底发生了什么的全部细节。但突然在1971年，有消息宣布林彪在企图对毛泽东发动政变失败后试图逃离北京，
becomes to realise that actually three years of this is probably enough, you know, the destruction of society. And as you say, the army, who are always very much behind, you know, all of these actions and very much on Mao's side, were brought in to shut this down. But that then essentially puts the army in charge of the Cultural Revolution. And Lin Biao, the Minister of Defence, who is very much at Mao's side, is in charge of doing that. There's then a sort of upheaval within the top leadership. And even now, we don't have the full details of quite what happened. But suddenly, in 1971, it was announced that Lin Biao had tried to sort of flee Beijing
并在蒙古人民共和国的某个地方因坠机身亡。实际上，如果你想要具体细节的话，是一架英国三叉戟喷气式飞机。因此，人们有一种感觉，即高层实际上存在着大量的动荡，而且并不完全清楚它将走向何方。那也是讨论理查德·尼克松访华的时代。那也是在文化大革命期间。这表明了你刚才谈到的那种派系斗争，汤姆。有一个以中国总理周恩来为首的集团，他们基本上想要引进美国人，因为他意识到中国不能永远与西方世界保持隔离。他们还需要外国投资。他们实际上在私下里将此作为修复文化大革命造成的破坏的一种手段。然后是后来被称为——当时没有，但后来被称为“四人帮”的集团，即毛泽东的妻子江青和其他三人，他们是绝对的强硬派激进分子，并说：不，你们在想什么，竟然让美国人进入中国？因此，关于地缘政治下一步会发生什么的宫廷阴谋正在发生，而与此同时，在更广阔的中国大地上，街头没有了红卫兵时期那种不加掩饰的暴力，但实际上有很多旧账被算清，你知道，在从1969年开始的剩余大部分时间里，一直到1976年毛泽东逝世文化大革命结束，人们在本质上、正如你所说的那样、在某种军事控制下被捕或被处决。
after attempting a coup against Mao and had been overthrown and died in an air crash in outer Mongolia of all places. Actually, in a British Trident jet, if you want the details. So there is this sort of feeling that actually there's an awful lot of turmoil at the top and it's not quite clear where it was going to end up. That was also the era when the visit of Richard Nixon was being discussed. That's also during the Cultural Revolution. And that shows the kind of factionalism that you were talking about there, Tom. There's a group led by Zhou Enlai, the Prime Minister of China, essentially, who wants to bring in the Americans because he realizes that China can't stay isolated from the Western world forever. And they also need foreign investment. They actually do talk about that in private as a means of repairing the damage that's been done by the Cultural Revolution. And then there's the group known later on,
如果我可以插话问一个关于周恩来的小问题。所以当尼克松来到中国时，他和基辛格花了很多时间陪毛泽东，他们也花了很多时间陪周恩来，他们似乎和周恩来相处得很好。在西方人眼里，周恩来看起来就像是二号人物，因为他非常知名。而他的养子和养女在这期间的文化大革命中都被折磨致死。所以，我的意思是，作为一个局外人，我觉得这对我来说是一件极其怪异的事情。我的意思是，那些在党内、在体制内显得如此权力滔天的人，却只是眼睁睁地、逆来顺受地站在一旁，看着自己的家人被摧毁。我的意思是，这发生在红卫兵时期之后。那么究竟是什么解释了这一切？
not at the time, but later on as the Gang of Four, Mao's wife, Jiang Qing, and three others, who are absolute hardline radicals and say, no, what on earth do you think you're talking about, letting the Americans into China? So all these palace intrigues about what happens next in geopolitics are going on while in wider China, there's less overt violence on the streets and the way that there was in the Red Guard period, but actually lots of scores being settled and, you know, people being either arrested or executed under essentially, as you say, sort of military control during much of the remaining period from 1969, all the way up to the end of the Cultural Revolution with Mao's death in 1976.
是因为他们太害怕军队了，还是因为宫廷阴谋而害怕失去自己的地位？还有另一个例子，多米尼克，邓小平，他后来成为1978年改革开放时期中国最高领导人。他的儿子邓朴方被红卫兵从窗户扔了下去，余生都在轮椅上度过。而且，你知道，那是邓小平，他最终将成为中国的最高统治者。即使你与人们交谈时，这仍然很难理解，虽然仍然有很多人活着，尽管他们通常很不愿详细谈论，要么是因为作为
Just a quick question, if I can jump in on Zhu Enlai. So when Nixon comes to China, he and Kissinger spent a lot of time in Mao, and they spent a lot of time with Zhu as well, and they seem to get on very well with Zhu Enlai. Zhu Enlai is, to Westerners, he looks like the number two man, because he's very well known. His adopted son and daughter are both tortured to death while this is going on during the cultural revolution. So, I mean, that's just a bizarre thing to be happening to me as an outsider. I mean, the people who appear to be so powerful within the party, within the apparatus, are just sort of meekly standing by while their family members are being destroyed. I mean, this is after the Red Guard period. So what explains all that?
受害者，他们依然感到深受创伤，要么是因为作为加害者——这类人也很多——他们真的不想谈论自己50年前在做什么。因此，很难进入你所谓的“人们的心理景观”，去了解他们的感受以及他们认为自己当时在做什么。但对于为什么如此资深、背景深厚的人会基本上袖手旁观、无所作为的问题，我认为有两个几乎相互矛盾的因素。一个是时间的不可预测性。你永远不知道自己什么时候会突然从政治局高层排名的人物，变成像中华人民共和国主席刘少奇那样的人。
Is that because they're so frightened of the army or frightened of losing their place because of the palace intrigues or what? And one other example there, Dominic, Deng Xiaoping, who goes on to become the paramount leader of China during the reform period from 1978 onwards. His son, Deng Pufang, was chucked out a window by Red Guards, and he has remained in a wheelchair for the rest of his life. And, you know, that's Deng Xiaoping, who eventually would become the overall ruler of China. It's still hard, even when you talk to people, and there are still plenty of them alive, although they're often quite reluctant to talk in detail, either because as
是因为他们太害怕军队，还是因为宫廷阴谋而害怕失去自己的地位，又或者是其他原因？多明尼克，这里还有另一个例子，邓小平，他在1978年改革开放时期成为了中国的最高领导人。他的儿子邓朴方被红卫兵从窗户扔了下去，导致他余生都只能坐在轮椅上。你知道，那是邓小平，他最终成为了中国的最高统治者。即使你跟人们交谈，情况依然很艰难，而且现在还有很多人健在，尽管他们往往很不愿详谈，要么是因为作为
victims, they still feel very traumatized, or because as perpetrators, and there are plenty of those people too, they really don't want to talk about what they were doing 50 years ago. So it's difficult to get into what you might call the emotional landscape of how people felt and what they thought they were doing. But in answer to the question of why such senior, well-connected people might essentially sit back and do so little, I think there are two factors which almost rub against each other. One was the unpredictability of the time. You did not know when you might suddenly shift from being someone who was ranked at the top level in the Politburo to being like Liu Shaoqi, the president of the People's Republic
受害者，他们依然感到极度创伤；要么是因为作为加害者（这样的人也很多），他们真的不想谈论自己50年前在做些甚么。因此，很难深入了解人们当时的心态和他们以为自己在做甚么的“情感世界”。但对于为什么如此资深、背景深厚的人会基本上袖手旁观、无所作为这个问题，我认为有两个因素几乎是相互矛盾的。一个是那个时代的不确定性。你根本不知道自己甚么时候会突然从政治局的高层人物，变成像中华人民共和国主席刘少奇那样的人。
of China, who was basically kidnapped, taken off and left to die of neglect of his medical condition in a windowless basement in the city of Kaifeng in central China. And that was the president of the People's Republic of China. You can imagine what it would have been like for some kind of mid-level bureaucrat in a city. Beyond that, though, I just remind you of what I was saying earlier, of understanding quite how pervasive the legend the myth the cult whatever you want to call it of Mao was again you know the sociologist Max Weber we've spoken about before he talked about charisma as a quality and charisma in the proper sense the ability to create this sort of wider sense of motivational power a coercive power Mao had it in spades you know none of the other leaders of
中国国家主席，基本上被绑架、被带走，并在中国中部开封市的一间没有窗户的地下室里任由其医疗状况恶化而死。而那是中华人民共和国的主席。你可以想象，对于一个城市里的某种中层官僚来说，情况会是怎样。除此之外，不过，我只想提醒你我刚才所说的，即要理解毛泽东的传奇、神话、个人崇拜——无论你想怎么称呼它——究竟是多么无孔不入。你知道，我们以前谈论过的社会学家马克斯·韦伯曾将魅力视为一种品质，而在真正的意义上，魅力是创造这种更广泛的动机力量、一种强制性力量的能力，毛泽东可谓具备得淋漓尽致。你知道，其他类型的领袖没有一个像他那样拥有这种特质
that sort had it quite that way Liu Xiaoxi certainly didn't he was a great bureaucrat even figures like Deng Xiaoping didn't really have it in quite that sort of a way but Mao was able to create a sort of transformative narrative with himself at the center which beguiled even his closest followers and those people even like Zhou Enlai who suffered so badly found themselves it seems unable to resist but runner when when mao dies you talked about the gang of four and they get brought to trial and they get convicted and the most prominent member of the gang of four is uh jiang ching a madam mao a former actress a kind of homicidal evita and she she's a very bad person i think she's a very bad person i would point's a very bad person i would say that
刘少奇当然没有，他是个伟大的官僚，甚至像邓小平这样的人物也没有真正拥有那种特质，但毛泽东能够创造一种以他自己为中心的变革性叙事，甚至迷住了他最亲密的追随者，而像周恩来那样遭受如此严重痛苦的人们也发现自己似乎无法抗拒。但拉娜，当毛去世时，你谈到了四人帮，他们被交付审判并被定罪，而四人帮中最显赫的成员是江青，毛夫人的前演员，一种杀人狂般的贝隆夫人，她她是个非常坏的人，我认为她是个非常坏的人，我会指出的非常坏的人，我会说
the peron regime was responsible for quite a few deaths as well but not quite that not quite that many um the the downfall of madam mao is that seen as a kind of signal that mao's magic has kind of been dispelled and is one of the long-term effects of the Cultural Revolution actually to kind of make Maoism defunct as a philosophy within contemporary China? Yeah, because we had to just jump in on that. I think we had a few questions about that, whether the Cultural Revolution actually paved, in a weird way, paved the way for Deng Xiaoping's reforms, for the openness, for the capitalism, all of that kind of stuff, whether those things might not have happened had the Cultural Revolution, as Tom says, almost slightly delegitimized radicalism. I think the best way to describe the treatment of Mao after his death and after the end of the Cultural Revolution, which came to an end very quickly
贝隆政权也导致了不少人的死亡，但没那么多，没那么多。嗯，毛夫人的倒台，这是否被视为一种信号，表明毛的魔法已经消散？文化大革命的长期影响之一，实际上是否让毛泽东主义在当代中国作为一种哲学而名存实亡？是的，因为我们必须马上切入这一点。我想我们有一些关于这方面的问题，关于文革是否实际上以一种诡异的方式为邓小平的改革、开放、资本主义以及所有这些铺平了道路，如果不是因为文革像汤姆所说的那样，几乎在某种程度上消解了激进主义的合法性，这些事情是否就不会发生。我认为描述毛泽东去世后以及文革结束后对毛泽东的处理方式的最好方法——文革非常迅速地迎来了终结
when his successor, Hua Guofeng, basically had the Gang of Four arrested in 1976, the best way to talk about it might be the sterilization of Maoism. I'll explain what I mean by that. When Madame Mao, when Jiang Qing was put on trial, she tried to blame it all on her late husband, saying, I was just Mao's little barking dog, why are you blaming me? And that's actually a perfectly legitimate thing to say, in a sense, had he not permitted the Gang of Four to do what they were going to do, then they wouldn't have
当他的继任者华国锋在1976年基本上将四人帮逮捕入狱时，谈论它的最好方式或许就是毛泽东主义的灭菌。我来解释一下我的意思。当毛夫人，也就是江青被审判时，她试图把一切都归咎于她已故的丈夫，说：“我只是毛泽东的一条小叫狗，你们为什么责怪我？”从某种意义上说，这其实是一个完全合乎逻辑的说法，如果不是他允许四人帮去做他们要做的事，那么他们就不会
been allowed to do it. But that, of course, wasn't what the post-Mao party wanted to hear. They did come up with a resolution through the party that grudgingly admitted blame and put some of the blame on Mao. But in the end, his charismatic quality as a leader was something they wanted to preserve. And therefore, they wanted to try and create a version of the Cultural Revolution, which is still essentially the official version, in which it was condemned as a terrible deviation and error and crime, and they don't cover that over, but essentially argue that Mao himself was not ultimately to blame and that it can be blamed on these figures such as the Gang of Four. And a certain amount of limited pathways were given to enable people to try and get their feelings out. One example that sort of blossomed from about 1977 to the early 80s was a genre called scar literature
被允许那样做。但那当然不是后毛泽东时代的党想要听到的。他们确实通过党的一份决议，勉强承认了错误，并把部分责任归咎于毛泽东。但最终，他作为领袖的领袖魅力是他想要保留的特质。因此，他们试图创造一个版本的文化大革命——这基本上仍然是官方版本——在其中，文革被谴责为一种可怕的偏差、错误和罪行，他们没有掩盖这一点，但基本上辩称毛泽东本人最终并不负有责任，责任可以归咎于四人帮等人物。并且给予了一定程度的有限渠道，让人能够尝试宣泄他们的感受。其中一个从1977年左右到80年代初蓬勃发展的流派被称为伤痕文学
in which some you know frankly in literary terms not very very good but certainly in emotional terms very powerful short stories about people's suffering under the cultural revolution were permitted for official publication and discussion and became part of a sort of healing of wounds at least relatively speaking, during that period. But even during that time, the live rail of the conversation was blaming Mao centrally and personally for what went on. Instead, finding figures like the Gang of Four as a sort of group of scapegoats who say, well, it was all them, somehow the rest of society got led astray, became the default mechanism. And since, as you said, China moved on pretty quickly towards, you know, much more kind of market oriented economy. After a while, people really
在那个流派中，有些人在文学意义上坦率地说并不是非常好，但在情感意义上非常震撼的短篇小说，讲述了人们在文化大革命期间遭受的苦难，被允许官方出版和讨论，并成为那个时期某种抚平伤创的一部分，至少相对而言是这样。但即便在那个时期，对话的高压线也是将文革的发生归咎于毛泽东的核心和个人。相反，将四人帮这样的人物找出来作为某种替罪羊，说“这一切都是他们的错，不知怎的其余社会被引入了歧途”，成了默认的机制。既然如你所说，中国相当迅速地转向了更具市场导向的经济。过了一段时间，人们真的
didn't want to spend too much time thinking about the horrors of that period anyway. And Rana, one last question on Xi Jinping, who, of course, the paramount leader of China today. He, I mean, he got caught up quite unpleasantly in the Cultural Revolution, didn't he? And I wonder, could you just say what happened to him and what you think the long term impact of that might be on his character and therefore perhaps on contemporary China? Absolutely. It's become quite well known as part of the personal narrative of Xi Jinping that he spent time in Shaanxi province in sort of northwest China, very traditional communist heartland, actually, it must be said, during his teenage years, because his father, Xi Jinping, who was one of the major military figures in Mao's China, fell out of political favor.
不想花太多时间去回想那个时期的恐怖了。拉娜，关于习近平的最后一个问题，他当然是今天中国的最高领导人。他，我的意思是，他在文化大革命中受到了相当不愉快的冲击，对吧？我想知道，你能不能说说他身上发生了什么，以及你认为那对他性格的长期影响可能是什么，从而也许对当代中国产生什么影响？当然。作为习近平个人叙事的一部分，这已经广为人知，他在少年时期曾在陕中西北部的陕西省度过一段时间，这里其实是一个非常传统的共产主义腹地，必须指出这一点，因为他的父亲习仲勋——毛泽东时代的主要军事人物之一——在政治上失势了。
And I think two things have come from that. One that is pretty negative, I think, and one that might be considered more positive. The negative is this. If you want to characterize Xi Jinping's politics, I think they are highly ideological, and he is reinventing Chinese politics for what he perceives as a global role. But it's also driven above anything else by a desperate fear of disorder and chaos, because he and his generation, too, I think, look back to the 60s and 70s and see a China which they perceived as having been allowed to basically spin out of control. The fact it was the Communist Party that did it is neither here nor there in this case. It's the idea that if you give China, you know, leeway, it will turn into a cultural revolution yet again. And that's one of the reasons, I think, for the obsessive level of surveillance, control and top down management
我认为由此产生了两个结果。一个是相当负面的，我认为，另一个可能被认为更加积极。负面的是这个。如果你想描述习近平的政治，我认为它们具有高度的意识形态性，他正在为他所设想的全球角色重新塑造中国政治。但最重要的是，它也是由对无序和混乱的绝望恐惧所驱动的，因为他和他的那代人，我也认为，回望60、70年代，看到一个他们认为被允许基本上失控的中国。在这个案例中，是共产党造成了这一点，这其实并不重要。核心观点是，如果你给中国余地，它就会再次变成文化大革命。我认为，这也是你今天在习近平领导下的中国共产党中看到的这种对监控、控制和自上而下管理的痴迷程度的原因之一
that you see in the Chinese Communist Party of today as led by Xi. It is a reaction, amongst other things, against the Cultural Revolution. But I said at the end on a partial positive, and I will. You can argue strongly that on everything from repression of Uyghurs in Xinjiang to the crackdown on Hong Kong, a great deal of Xi Jinping's politics have been about the suppression of civil liberties. I think that's not really in doubt. But you can also argue that there is one strand that is authentic, which is a continuing obsession also with economic inequality and poverty. And a lot of people, probably he himself, would argue that that period of several years spent in one of the most dirt poor, desperate parts of China that,
这是对文化大革命等历史的反动。但我刚才说会以部分积极的观点结束，我也会这么做。你可以强有力地辩称，从在新疆对维吾尔族的镇压到对香港的打击，习近平的很大一部分政治都围绕着对公民自由的压制。我认为这确实没有什么悬念。但你也可以辩称，其中还有一个真实的线索，那就是对经济不平等和贫困的持续痴迷。许多人，可能他自己也会辩称，在那个中国最赤贫、最绝望的地区之一度过几年的经历——
as he would have seen, even after 2025 years of the Communist Revolution, had not leveled up, to use a phrase that is perhaps current in a different sort of politics, that was still very, very desperately impoverished, may have put this sense in his mind that if he was going to do one thing in terms of China's economy, it will be to try and make sure that it had more of a both poverty reduction element and also an egalitarian element in terms of economics than perhaps his predecessors as party chairman had put forward. And those things, I think, can both in a sort of, in a fairly direct way, be attributed to his personal experience during those years of the Cultural Revolution. Fascinating. Thank you so much, Rana. I mean, it's an amazing topic. And I
正如他所看到的，甚至在共产主义革命25年后，也没有实现“拉平”——用一种或许在不同政治语境中时髦的短语来说，那里依然非常非常绝望地贫困——可能在他脑海中埋下了一种观念：如果要在中国经济方面做一件事，那就是努力确保它比他作为党主席的前任们提出过的方案，拥有更多减少贫困的元素，以及在经济上更多的平均主义元素。我认为，这两点在某种程度上、以相当直接的方式，都可以归因于他在文革那些年里的个人经历。太迷人了。非常感谢你，拉娜。我的意思是，这是一个了不起的话题。我知道
know some of our listeners will say, oh my God, there's so much more you could have talked about. I mean, we could, of course, but that's an absolutely wonderful overview. Tom, do you not agree? I mean, I learned a huge amount and you didn't get to talk about Christianity, which gave me a lot of satisfaction. No, but Rana did. Yeah, but Rana did to talk about christianity which gave me a lot of satisfaction no but rana did yeah but rana did but rana did that gave me a lot of but rana did it with so much he did it he did it he did it so much more succinctly than i'm used to on this podcast tom yes yes yes okay well rana can't thank you enough that was absolutely brilliant um and uh i hope you know we can persuade you to come back oh definitely um other aspects of china because there's so much to discuss.
我的一些听众会说，哦天哪，你们本可以讨论更多事情。我的意思是，我们当然可以，但这是一个绝对精彩的概述。汤姆，难道你不这么认为吗？我的意思是，我学到了很多东西，而且你没有谈论基督教，这让我感到非常满意。不，但拉娜讲了。是的，但拉娜确实谈到了基督教，这让我感到非常满意。不，但拉娜讲了。是的，但拉娜讲了，拉娜讲这个的时候，他的表达比我在这档播客里习惯的要精炼得多，汤姆。是的，是的，好吧，拉娜，真是感激不尽，那绝对太棒了，嗯，我希望你知道我们能说服你再次做客，哦，当然，嗯，关于中国的其他方面，因为有太多东西可以讨论了。
Dominic and Tom, it's been a pleasure to worship at the altar of cult of personality at the podcast with the mostest. And I very much hope this is just a conversation laid down for now and to be picked up on a future occasion. It's been a great pleasure. Definitely.
多米尼克和汤姆，能在拥有最多粉丝的播客中，在个人崇拜的圣坛前顶礼膜拜，这真是我的荣幸。我非常希望这只是暂时搁置、留待未来某个场合继续探讨的一场对话。这真是莫大的荣幸。当然。
If you're going to talk like that, you can definitely come back. Thanks so much, Robert. Bye-bye. And thanks everyone for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye and thanks everyone for listening bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening
如果你要这么说话，你绝对可以再来。非常感谢，罗伯特。再见。也谢谢大家的聆听。再见。再见，谢谢大家收听，再见，再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History），如需收听独家节目、抢先体验、免广告收听
and access to our chat community please sign up up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦花边。在我们的问答环节中，我们带你一探娱乐幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要免广告收听、独家节目
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。